the use of data analytics has been
rapidly growing with companies looking
to generate insights and drive their
business with the help of data
hey everyone welcome to this full course
video on data analytics
in this video we will learn data
analytics from scratch and analyze data
using python and our programming
language
we have our experienced instructors
richard avijit akshata and shruti
who will help you learn data analytics
in detail
in this video you will learn what is
data analytics and why data analytics
we look at the different types of data
analytics and see
the various applications of data
analytics then
you will understand a case study and
perform analysis
of data using python and r after that
we'll see the top 10 data analysis tools
and understand the difference between a
data scientist
and a data analyst finally we'll look at
the top interview questions
that will help you crack a data analyst
interview we will learn all of these
under 5 hours
over to richard now welcome to data
analytics using python
my name is richard kirschner with the
simply learn team that's
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead so we're going
to cover data analytics with python
we're going to go over what is data
analytics applications of data analytics
types of data analytics data analytics
process steps
why python for data analytics and then
we'll dive into use case demo so you can
actually see some script and actually
see what it looks like
in the python code what is data
analytics
data analytics is a process of exploring
and analyzing large datasets to make
predictions
and help data-driven decision-making now
the definition of large datasets keeps
changing
and so this can range really from just
about anything to anything
but usually in today's world we're
talking significantly larger amounts of
data that you can't just glance at and
try to figure it out yourself
and the two steps are analyze the data
and then make decisions based on the
data
applications of data analytics now
the sky's a limit on this in today's
world almost every business
act of life your music on your spotify
are driven by data analytics but some of
the big players when you go in their job
hunting are going to be your fraud
analysis
if you want to go make a lot of money
and you're good at it and you like
dealing with numbers
go join the banks and track down the
criminals who are stealing money it's a
lot of you know it's a big thing to
protect
credit cards protect sales purchases bad
checks
any of those things when you can track
them down is huge
healthcare exploding there is everything
from
trying to find cures for the covet virus
or any of the viruses out there
using your cell phone to diagnose
different ailments
that way you don't have to go and see
the doctor you can actually just go in
there and take a picture of the
funky growth on your arm hopefully it's
not too big and then they send it in
there and the data analyst goes in there
looks at it and says oh this is what
this is this is a professional you need
to go see
or don't need to see and that's just one
aspect of healthcare
the databases being generated by
healthcare and getting the right doctors
and helping the doctors analyze whether
something
is benign or malignant if it's cancerous
all those things are now part of the
ongoing healthcare growth
in data analytics inventory management
think one of those huge warehouses where
they're shipping out all the goods
how do you inventory that in such a way
so that
you maximize the stuff that's being
purchased the most near the entrance and
all the other stuff towards the back or
even pre-ship it
so it's huge to be able to inventory the
manager inventory
and pretty soon they'll just have a
drone come in there and start picking up
some of those boxes and move them around
also
deliver your logistics again this goes
from getting from point a to point b
you can combine it with our inventory so
you pre-ship stuff if you know
a certain area is more likely to
purchase it how do you get it the
delivery
to the most destinations the quickest in
the short amount of time
and then they even pre-stack the trucks
going out and that's all done with data
analytics
how do we stack all that stuff so it
comes out in the right order
targeted marketing huge industry any
kind of marketing whether you're
generating
uh the right content for the marketing
who are you targeting with that
marketing
researching the people what they want so
you know what products to market out
there
all those things are huge and these are
just a few
examples you can probably go way beyond
this from tracking forest fires
to astrology and studying the stars all
of this is part of data analytics now
and plays a
huge role in all these different areas
city planning is another one you know
you can see a nice organized city like
this one where you can get in and out of
the neighborhoods if you're a fire truck
police officers need to be able to get
in and out you want your tourists to be
able to come in
you still want the place to look nice
and you have the right commercial
development the right
industrial development like enough
residents for people to stay
all those things are part of your city
planning again
huge in data analytics so
sky's the limit on what you use it for
let's take a look at types of data
analytics
and this can be broken up in so many
ways but we're going to start with
looking at the most
basic questions that you're going to be
asking in data analytics
and the first one is you want
descriptive analytics what has happened
hindsight how many cells per call ratio
coming out of the call
center if we have 500 tourists in a
forest
and you have a certain temperature how
many fires were started how many times
did the police have to show up to
certain houses
all that's descriptive the next one is
predictive
predictive analytics is what will happen
next we want to predict
uh this is great if you have a ice cream
store and you want to predict
how many people to work at the ice cream
store in a certain day
based on the temperature coming up in
the time of the year
and then one of the biggest growing and
most important parts of the industry is
now prescriptive
analytics and you can think of that as
combining the first two we have
descriptive
and we have predictive then you get pre
descriptive
analytics how can we make it happen
foresight what can we change to make
this work better
in all the industries we looked at
before we can start asking questions
especially in city development there's a
good one if we want to
have our city generate more income and
we want that income to be commercial
based
what kind of commercial buildings do we
need to build in that area that are
going to bring people over
do we need huge warehouse sales costco
sales buildings
or do we need little mom pod joints that
are going to bring in
people from the country to come shop
there or do you want an industrial setup
what do you need to bring that industry
in there is our car industry available
in that
area if it's not a car industry what
other industries are in that area
all those things are prescriptive we're
guessing we're guessing what can we do
to fix it
what can we do to fix crime in area with
education what kind of education are we
going to use
to help people understand what's going
on so that we lower the rate of crime
and we help our communities grow better
that's all prescriptive it's all
guessing we want foresight into how can
we make it happen how can we make this
better
and we really can't not go into enough
detail on these three
because a lot of people stumble on this
when they come in and are doing
analytics
whether you're the manager shareholder
or
the data scientist coming in you really
need to understand the descriptive
analytics where you're studying the
total units of furniture sold
and the profit that was made in the past
here we go into predictive analytics
predicting the total units that would
sell and the profit we can expect in the
future
gear up for how many employees we need
how much money we're going to make
and prescriptive analytics finding ways
to improve the sales and the profit so
we can
sell maybe a different kind of furniture
we're going to guess at what the area is
looking for and how that
marketing is going to change data
analytics
process steps so let's take a look at
some of the basic processing and what
that looks like when you're working with
this data
so there's five basic steps uh the five
steps of processing and and this changes
and then there's a lot of things that go
on when they talk about
um agile programming the whole concept
of agile is you take some kind of
framework like this
and then you build on it depending on
what your business needs
so the first step is data collection
and usually with a large company you
might have somebody who
is responsible for the database
management
you might have another one where they're
pulling apis and they're pulling data
off of
maybe the census bureau maybe something
very very specific domain specific so if
you're analyzing
cancerous growths and how to understand
them then the data collection is going
to be those measurements they take from
the mri
or it might be even the mri images
they've used those also
so there's a lot of things with data
collection and how to
control that and make sure it has what
you need and is clean
and you don't have miss information
coming in
once you have the data collected there's
a data preparation
so stage two is we take that data and we
format it into something we can use
probably one of the biggest formats that
you see is when you're processing text
how do you process text well you use
what they call a
one hot encoder and each word is
represented
by a yes no kind of setup so it'd be
like a long
array of bits um that's one way to
prepare it
and so you know bit number one is the
bit number two
is has or whatever it is other
preparations might be if you're using
neural networks you might be
taking integers or float numbers and
converting them to a value between zero
and one
that way you don't have one of them
creating a bias in there
so there's a lot of different things
that go into data preparation that is 80
of data science so we talk about the
data
analytics which is a little bit more on
the math side and they usually say talk
about a data scientist kind of being the
overall
preparer of this stuff you're going to
spend 80 percent of your data
preparation
data exploration uh that's the fun part
this is where you're exploring things uh
and it is
maybe ten to fifteen percent of what you
do with the data you spend with the data
exploration
it is probably the most important step
because this is where you got to start
asking questions
if you ask your questions wrong you're
going to get some wrong information
if you're working with a company and
they want to know the marketing values
then you really got to focus on hey how
do we generate money for this company
or fraud how do we lower the fraud rate
while still generating a profit
four data modeling this is where we
start actually getting into the data
code
which model to use that predicts what's
going to happen
uh and then result interpretation we
want to be able to interpret those
results you usually see that in your
matplot library where you create nice
beautiful images so it shows up on their
dashboard for the marketing
manager or for the ceo so they can take
a quick look and say hey i can see
what's going on there
you want to reduce it to something they
can easily read
they don't want to hear the scientific
terms they want to see something they
can use
and we'll talk about that a little bit
more when we start looking at some of
this in a demo
since this is data analysis with python
we've got to ask the question why python
for data analytics
i mean there's c plus there's java
there's
dot net from microsoft why do people go
to python for it
so the number of reasons one it's easy
to learn with simple
syntax you don't have a very
high type set like you do in java and
other coding
so it allows you to kind of be a little
lazy in your programming
that doesn't mean that it can't be set
that way and that you don't have to be
careful it just
means you can spin up a code much
quicker in python
the same amount of code to do something
in python a lot of times is one two or
three or four lines
where when i did the same thing say in
java i found myself with 10
12 13 20 lines depending on what it was
it's very scalable and flexible so
there's our flexibility because you can
do a lot with it
and you can easily scale it up you can
go from something on your machine
to using pi spark under the spark
environment and spread that across
hundreds if not thousands of servers
across terabytes of data or petabytes of
data
so it's very scalable there's a huge
collection of
libraries this one's always interesting
because
java has a huge collection of libraries
c has a huge collection of libraries
dot net does and they're always in
competition to get those libraries out
scala for your spark all those have huge
collections of libraries
this is always changing but because
python is open source
you almost always have easy to access
libraries that anybody can use you don't
have to go check your licensing and have
special licensing like you do in some
packages
graphics and visualization they have a
really powerful package for that so it
makes it easy to create nice displays
for
people to read and community support
because python is open source it has a
huge community that supports it
you can do a quick google and probably
find a solution for almost anything
you're working on
python libraries let's bring it together
we have data analytics
and we have python so when we're talking
data analytics
we're talking python libraries for data
analytics
and the big five players are numpy
pandas
matplot library scipy which is going to
be in the background so we're not going
to talk too much about the
scientific formulas inside pi in scikit
so numpy supports n-dimensional arrays
provides numerical computing tools
useful for linear algebra
and fourier transform and you can think
of this as just a grid of numbers
and you can even have a grid inside a
grid
or data it's not even numbers because
you can also put
words and characters and just about
anything into that array
but you can think of a grid and then you
can have a grid inside a grid and you
end up with a nice three-dimensional
array
if you want to talk three-dimensional
array you can think of images
you have your three channels of color
four if you have an alpha
and then you have your xy coordinates
for the image we're looking at so you
can go x
y and then what are the three channels
to generate that color
and numpy isn't restricted to three
dimensions you could imagine
watching a movie well now you have your
movie clips and they each have their x
number of frames and each of those
frames have
x number of x y coordinates for the
pictures in each frame and then you have
your
three dimensions for the colors so numpy
is just a great way to work with
in-dimensional arrays
now closely with numpy is pandas
useful for handling missing data perform
mathematical operations
provides functions to manipulate data
pandas is becoming huge because it is
basically a data frame
and if you're working with big data and
you're working in spark or any of the
other major packages out there
you realize that the data frame is very
central to a lot of that and you can
look at it as a
excel spreadsheet you have your columns
you have your rows
or indexes and you can do all kinds of
different manipulations of the data
within
including filling in missing data which
is a big thing when you're dealing with
large pools or lakes of data where they
might be collected differently from
different
locations and matplot
library we did kick over the sci pi
which is a lot of mathematical
computations which usually runs in the
background of the for of numpy and
pandas
um although you do use them they're
useful for a lot of other things in
there
but the matte plot library that's the
final part that's what you want to show
people and this is your plotting library
in python
several toolkits extend matplot library
functionality
there's like a hundred different
toolkits to extend matplot library
which range from how to properly display
star constellations from astronomy
there's a very specific one built just
for that
all the way to some very generic ones
we'll actually add seaborne in when we
do the labs in a minute
several toolkits extend map plot library
functionality and it creates
interactive visualization so there's all
kinds of cool things you can do as far
as just displaying graphs and there's
even some that you can create
interactive graphs we won't do the
interactive graphs but you'll see you'll
get a
pretty good grasp of some of the
different things you can do in matplot
library
let's jump over to the demo which is my
favorite roll up our sleeves
get our hands in on what we're doing now
there's a lot of options when we're
dealing with python
you can use pycharm is a really popular
one
and you'll see this all over the place
so it's one of the main ones that's out
there and there's a lot of other ones i
used to use netbeans which is kind of
lost favor
don't even have it installed on my new
computer but the most popular one right
now for data
science now pycharm is really popular
for python general development
for data science we usually go to
jupiter
notebook or anaconda and we're going to
jump into anaconda because that's my
favorite one to go to because it has a
lot of external tools for us
we're not going to dig into those but we
will pop in there so you can see what it
looks like
so with anaconda we have our jupiter lab
we have our notebook these are identical
jupiter lab
is an upgrade to the notebooks with
multiple tabs that's all it is
and we'll be using the notebook and you
can see that pycharm is so popular with
python that we even have highlighted
here in anaconda as part of the setup
jupiter notebook can also be a
standalone so we're actually going to be
running
jupiter notebook and then you have your
different environments
i have we're going to be under main pi
36 there's a root one
and i usually label it pi three six the
reason is is currently as of writing
this
tensorflow only works in three six and
not in three seven or three eight for
doing neural networks
but you can actually have multiple
environments which is nice there
they separate the kernels so it helps
protect your computer when you're doing
development
and this is just a great way to do a
display or a demo
especially if you're looking for that
job pull up your laptop open it up
or if you're doing a meeting get it
broadcast up to the big screen so that
the
ceo can see what you're looking at
and when we launch the notebook it
actually opens up a file browser in
whatever web browser you have this
happens to be chrome
and then you can just go under new
there's a lot of different options
depending what you have installed
python 3 and this just creates an
untitled
version of this and you can see here i'm
actually in a simply learn folder for
other work i've done for simply learn
and that's where i save all my stuff and
i can browse through other folders
making it real easy to jump from one
project to another
and under here we'll go ahead and change
the name of this and we'll go ahead and
rename it
data analytics data analytics
just so i can remember what i was doing
which is probably about 50 of the
folders in here right or files in here
right now
so let's go ahead and jump in there and
take a look at some of these different
uh tools that we were looking at
and as we go through the demo let's
start with the uh
numpy uh the least visually exciting and
i'm gonna
zoom in here so you can see what we're
doing
and the first thing we want to do is
import numpy
and we'll import it as np that is the
most common
numpy terminology and let's go ahead and
change the view so we also have the line
numbers
i don't know why we probably won't need
them but like it for easy reference
and then we'll create a one dimensional
array we'll just call this array1
and it equals np.array and you put your
array information in here in this case
we'll spell it out
you can actually do like a range in
other ways there's lots of ways to
generate these arrays
but we'll just do one two three so three
integers
and if we print our array one
we can go ahead and run this and you can
see right here prints one two three
you can see why this is a really nice
interface to show other people what
you're doing
uh with the jupiter notebook so this is
the basic we've created an array this is
a one dimensional array and then the
array is one two three
one of the nice things about the jupiter
notebook is whatever ran
in this first setup is still running
it's still in the kernel
so it still has the numpy imported as np
and it still has our variable
arr1 for array one equal to np array of
one two three
so when we go to the next cell we can
check
the type of the array we're just going
to print we say hey what's
what what is this setup in here and we
want type
and then we want what is the type of
array one
let's go ahead and run that and it says
class
numpy nd array so it's its own class
that's all we're doing is
checking to see what that class is
and if you look at the array class uh
probably the biggest thing you do
i don't know how many times i find
myself doing this
because i forget what i'm working on and
i forget i'm working with a
three-dimensional or four-dimensional
array
and i have to reformat somehow so it
works with whatever
other things i have and so we do the
array shape
the ray shape is just three because it
has three members and it's a one
dimensional array that's all that is
and with the numpy array we can easily
access
stick with the print statement if you
actually put a variable
in jupiter notebook and it's the last
one in the cell
it will be the same as a print statement
so if i do this
where array one of two is the same as
doing print
array of two that's those are identical
statements in our jupiter notebook
we'll go and stick with the print on
this one and it's three so there's our
print space
two and we have zero one two
two equals three we can easily change
that
so we have array one of place two
equals five and then if we print our
array one
uh you can see right down here when it
comes out it's one two and five
and there i left the print statement off
because it's the last variable in the
list
it'll always print the variable if you
just put it in like that
that's a jupiter notebook thing don't do
that in pycharm i've forgotten before
doing a demo
and we talked about multiple dimensions
so we'll do an array
two-dimensional array and this is again
a numpy array
and in the numpy array we need um
our first dimension we'll do one two
three
and our second dimension
uh three four five and you can see right
here
that when we hit the uh we'll do this
we'll just do array two
and we can run that and there's our
array two one two three three four
five we can also do array two
of uh one and then we can do
let's do zero it doesn't really matter
which one actually just do
two there we go and if i run this it
will print out five
because here we are this is zero
zero one two three is on our zero row
three four five is on our one row and we
start with zero
and then the two zero one two goes to
the five
and then maybe we forgot what we were
working with so we're going to do array2
dot
shape
and if we do array 2 of shape
we'll go and run that we'll see we have
2 rows
and each row has 3 elements a
two-dimensional array
two three if you looked up here when we
did it before it just had three
comma nothing when you have a single
entity it always saves it as a tuple
with a blank space
uh but you can see right here we have
two comma three
and if you remember from up here we just
did this array two of oh let's go what
is it one
comma two
we run that we get the five you can also
count backwards this is kind of fun
and you'll see i just kind of switch
something on you because you can also do
one comma two to get to the same spot
now two is the last one zero one two
it's the last one in there
we can count backwards and do minus one
and if we run this
we get the same answer whether we count
it as
let's go back up here whether we count
this as zero one two
or we count backwards as minus 1 minus 2
minus 3. and you can see that if i
change this minus 1 to a minus 2 and run
that
i get 4 which is going backwards minus 1
minus 2.
so there's a lot of different ways to
reference what we're working on
inside the numpy array it's really a
cool tool it's got a lot of things you
can do with it
and we talked about the fact that it can
also hold things that are not
values and we'll call this array s for
strings
equals np.array
put our setup in there brackets
and let's go china
um india
usa mexico
matter we can make whatever we want on
here and if we print that out
and we run this you can see that we get
an our numpy of ray china india usa
mexico
it even gives us our d type of a u6
and a lot of times when you're messing
with data we'll call this array
r for range just to kind of keep it
uniform
in p dot a range
so this is a command inside numpy to
create a range of numbers
and if you're testing data maybe you
want maybe you have equal time
increments that are spaced a certain
point apart but in this case we're just
going to do
integers and we're going to do
a setup from 0 20 skipping every other
one
and we'll print it out and see what that
looks like
and you can see here we have 0 2 4 6 8
10 12 14 16 18 like you expected it
skips every one
and just a quick note
there's no 20 on here why well this
starts at
0 and counts up to 20.
so if you're used to another language
where explicitly says
less than or less than equal to 20 like
for x
equals 0 x plus plus
x is less than 20. that's what this is
it just assumes
x is less than 20 on here and if we want
to create a very
uniform set you know 0 2 4 6
what happens if i want to create numbers
from 0 to 10 but i need 20 increments in
there
we can do that with line space so we can
create
an r we'll call this l
equals i don't think we'll actually use
any of this again so i don't know why
i'm
creating unique identifiers for it uh
but we'll do np
lin space
and we're gonna do 0 to 10 or 0 to 9
remember it doesn't it goes up to 10.
and then we want to let's say we have
20 different
increments in there so we're creating a
we have a data set and we know it's over
a certain time period
and we need to divide that time period
by 20 and it happens to just have 10
pieces in it and here we go you can see
right here
we have 20 or it has 20 pieces in it but
it's over 10 years
we got divided in the middle and you can
see it does it goes zero
point five two remember yeah there's our
ten on the end so it goes up to ten
uh and then we can also do random
there's np.random
if you're doing neural networks usually
you start it by
seeding it with random numbers and we'll
just do
np.random and we'll just call this array
we'll stop giving it unique numbers
we'll print that one out and run it and
you can see we have
random numbers they are zero to one so
you'll see that all these numbers are
under one
and you can easily alter that by
multiplying them out or something like
that if you want to do like zero to a
hundred
you can also round them up if it's
integer 0 to 100 there's all kinds of
things you can do but generates
a random float between 0 and 1. and you
have a couple options you could reshape
that
or you can just generate them in
whatever shape
you want and so we can see here uh we
did three and four
and so you can see three rows by four
variables
same thing as doing a reshape of 12
variables to three and four
and if you're going to do that you might
need an empty data set um
i have had this come up many times
where i need to start off with zero and
i don't know you know because i'm going
to be adding stuff in there
or it might be zero and one where one is
if you're removing the background of an
image
you might want the background is zero
and then
you figure out where the image is and
you set all those boxes to one and you
create a mask
so creating masks over images is really
big
and doing that with a numpy array of
zero
and we can also uh
give it a space and we'll just do this
all in one shot this time
and we'll do the same thing like we did
before
zeros and in this case we'll do uh two
comma three
and so when we run this
i forgot the asterisks around it i knew
i was forgetting something there we go
so when we run this you can see here we
have
our 10 zeros in a row and maybe this is
a mask for an image
and so it has two rows of three
digits in it so it's a very small image
a little tiny pixel
and maybe you're looking to do something
the opposite way
instead of creating a mask of zeros and
filling in with ones
maybe you want to create a mask of ones
and fill them in
with zeros and we'll just do just like
we did before with the three comma four
and when we run this you'll see it's all
ones and we could even do this even
we'll do it this way let's do 10
10 by 10 icon and then you have your
three colors
so creates quite a large array there for
doing pictures and stuff like that when
you add that third dimension in
if we take that off it's a little bit
easier to see
we'll do 10 again
and you can easily see how we have 10
rows of 10 ones
and you can also do something like
create an array
and we'll do 0 1 2.
and then in this array we actually
print it right out we want a repeat
so you can actually do a repeat of the
array and maybe you need this array
let's repeat it three times so there's
our repeat of an array repeat three
times
and if we run this you'll see we have
zero zero zero one one one two two two
and whenever i think of a repeat i don't
really think of
repeating being the first digit three
times the second digit
i really always think of it as
0 1 2 0 1 2 0 1 2. it catches me
every time but the actual code for that
one
is going to be tile and again if we do a
range
three and we run this
you can see how you can generate one
zero one two zero one two zero one two
and if you're dealing with an identity
matrix we can do that also if you're big
on you're doing your matrixes
and we'll just uh identity i guess we'll
go ahead and spell it out today
may tricks
and the command we're looking for is
i e-y-e and we'll do three and then
we'll just go ahead and print this out
there we go there's our identity matrix
and it comes out by a three by three
array because there's our matrix
and then it puts the ones down the
middle and for doing your different
matrix math
and we can manipulate that a little bit
too
we talk about matrixes
we might not want ones across the middle
in which case we now have
the diagonal so we can do an np dot
diagonal
and we do a diagonal let's put in the
diagonal
one two three four five and when we run
this
again this generates a value and by just
putting that value in there's the same
as putting print around it or putting
array equals and then print array
and you can see it generates a diagonal
one two three four five and there's your
your beginning of your matrix array for
working with matrixes
and we can actually go in reverse let's
create an array
equals remember our random
random.random and we'll do a five by
five array
uh oops there we go five by
five and just so you can see what that
looks like
helps if i don't miss type the numbers
which in this case i just need to take
out the brackets and there you go you
have your
your five by five array set up in there
and we can now
because we're working with matrixes we
might want to do this in reverse and
extract
the diagonals which would be the 0.79
the 0.678 and so on
and we simply type in np dot diagonal
and we put our array in there and this
will of course print it out because it
returns it as a variable
and you can see here here's our diagonal
going across from our matrix
and we did talk about shape earlier if
you remember you can do
print the shape out you can also do the
dimensions
so in dimensions very similar to shape
it comes out and just has two dimensions
we can also look at the size so if we do
size on here
we can run that you can see has a size
of 25 two dimensions and of course five
by five
and that was from the shape from earlier
that we looked at
there's our five by five shape and if
you remember earlier we did random
well you can also do uh random i talked
a little bit about manipulating 0 to 1
and how you can get different answers
you can also do straight for the integer
part and we'll do minus
10 to 10
4 and so we're going to generate random
integers between minus 10 to 10.
we're going to generate four of those
once we run that we have 7 minus 3 minus
6 minus 3.
they're all between minus 10 and 10 and
there's four of them
and now we jump into some of the
functionality of
arrays which is really great because
this is where they come in
here's your array and you can add 10 to
it and if i run this
there takes my original array from up
here
with the integers and adds 10 to all of
those values so now we have oh this is
the decimal that's right this is a
random decimal i had stored an array
but this takes a random decimal the
random numbers i had from 0 to 1
and adds 10 to them and we can just as
easily do
minus 10.
we could even do
times two
and we could do divide by two and it
would it'll take that
random number we generated and cut in
half so now all these numbers are under
0.5
another way you can change the numbers
to what you need on there
and as you dig deeper into numpy we can
also do exponential
so as an exponential function which
would generate some interesting numbers
off of the random
so we're taking them to the power i
don't even remember what the original
numbers in the
array were because we did the random
numbers up there here's our original
numbers
and if you build an exponential on there
uh this is where you get e to the x on
this and just like you can do e to the x
you can also do the log so if you're
doing logarithmic functions
that reinforced learning you might be
doing some kind of log setup on there
and you can see the logarithmic of these
different
array numbers and if you're working with
uh log base 2 you can do you can just
change it in there in p
log 2. you have to look it up because
this is not
log 1 2 3 4 5. it is log and log
2 so just a quick note that's not a
variable going in
that is an actual command there's a
number of them in there
and you'll have to go look and see what
the documentation is
but you can also do log 10. so here's
log value 10.
some other really cool functions you can
do with this is your sign
so we can take a sine value of all of
our different values in there
and if you have sine you of course have
cosine
we can run that so here's the cosine of
those
and if you're doing activations in your
numpy array and you're doing a tangent
activation
there's your tangent for that and the
tangent activation is actually from
neural networks that's one of the ways
you can activate it because it forms a
nice
curve between from whether you're
generating
one to negative one with some
discrepancy in the middle
just jumping a little bit in there into
neural networks
and then we get into let me just put the
array back out there so that we can see
it
while we're doing this as we're getting
into this you can also sum the values so
we have np
sum and you can do a summation of all
the values in this array
and you'll see that if you added all
these together they'd equal 12.519
and so on i don't know what the whole
setup is in there
but you can see right here the the
summation of this one of the things you
can also do is by
axes so we could do axes equals zero
and if we run the summation of the axis
equals zero
and you can think of that in numpy
as the rows so that would be or
you can think of that in numpy as being
the columns we're summing these columns
going across
and you can also change this to one and
now we're summing the rows
and so that is the summation of this row
and so forth and so forth going down
and maybe you don't need to
know the summation maybe what you're
looking for is the minimum
so here's our minimal you're looking for
and this comes up a lot because you have
like your errors we want to find the
minimal error
inside of this array and just like
the other one we can do axes equals 0.
and you can see here 0.0645 is the
smallest number in this first column is
0.0645 and so on
and if you have a minimum well you might
also want to know the max maybe we're
looking for the maximum profit
and here we go you can see maximum 0.79
is the maximum on this first column
and just like we did before you can
change this to a 1
on axes you can take the axes out of
here
and just find the max value for the
whole array and the max value in here
was 0.8344
so on so on and since we're talking data
analytics
we want to go ahead and look at the mean
pretty much the same as the average this
is the mean across the whole thing
and just like we did before we could
also do axes equals zero
and then you'll see this is the mean of
this axis and so on
and we have mean we might want to know
the median
and there's our median our most common
numbers if we have median we might want
to know the standard deviation
or if we have the average a lot of times
you do the means and the standard
deviation
we can run that and there's our standard
deviations along the axes
we can also do it across the whole array
uh if we're going to do standard
deviations there's also
variance which is your var
and there's our variance across the
different levels
and so if we looked at that we looked at
variance we looked at standard deviation
the median and the means there's more
but those are the most common ones
used with data analytics and then going
through your data and figuring out
what you're going to present to the
shareholders
and some other things we can do is we
can actually take slices
uh you'll hear that terminology and a
slice
might be like we have a five by five
array but maybe we don't want the whole
array
maybe we want uh from one on we don't
want the zero in there
so we got up to four and maybe on the
second part we
just want two
to row three and see this notation right
here says
one to the end and if we run this you
can see how that generates
a single row to the end and then row two
and three
now remember it doesn't include three
that's why we only get the one column
so if you wanted two and three you would
need to go ahead and go two to four
so it goes up to four we could also do
this in reverse
just like we learned earlier we can go
minus one oops
and when we go to minus one it's the
same thing because we have zero
one two three four this is the same
thing as two to four it goes two to the
last one
also very common with arrays is you're
going to want to sort them so we still
have our array up here
that we randomly generated and we might
want to
sort it and we'll go and throw an axis
back in there
axis equals one if we run this you can
see from the axes that it sorts it
uh the point two being the lowest value
to the highest value
by the row we can also change this of
course to axis zero
if you're sorting it by column so maybe
your values are based on columns
and then of course you can do the whole
array and we can sort that
don't usually do that but you know i
guess sometimes you might that might
come up
and so you can see right here we have a
nice sorted array
something else let's just go ahead and
reprint our array so we can look at it
again
starting to get too many boxes up there
something else you can do with an array
is we can take and transpose it
this comes up more than you would think
when you transpose it you'll see
that the rows in the column are
transposed so where
0.79.57 0.064
is a column now we've switched it and we
have 0.79.42
as the index
you can see this really more dramatic if
we take a slice
and we'll just do a slice of the first
couple and then we'll just do all the
other
the full rows and if we run this you can
see how it comes up a little bit
different and we'll just do the same
slice up here so you can see how those
two look next to each other
there we go there's our slice run and so
you can see the slice comes up and it
has
one two three four five columns now we
have one two three four
five rows and three columns versus three
rows
and the original version when they first
started putting this
together was a function so the original
version was
transpose and this still works you can
still see it generates the same value as
just a capital t
so many times we flip this data because
we'll have an x y
value or we'll have an image or
something like that and it's being read
one way into
the next process and the next one needs
it the opposite
so this actually happens a lot you need
to know how to transpose the data really
quick
and we can go ahead oh let's just take
here's our transpose we'll just stick
with the transpose on here
and instead of doing it this way we
might need to do something called
flattening
why would you flatten your data if this
is an array going into
a neural network you might want to send
it in as one set of values instead of
two rows
and you can see here is all the values
as a single array it just flattens it
down into one array
so we covered our scientific means
transpose
median some different variations on here
some of the other things we want to do
is what happens if we want to append
to our array so let's create a new array
i'm getting tired of looking at the same
set of random numbers we generated
earlier
so we'll go ahead and create a new array
here something a little simpler so it's
easier to see what we're doing
four five six seven eight uh that's good
enough for this two four five six seven
eight
and if we print this array there it is
four five six seven
eight and we might to append something
to the array
so we have our array we need to extend
it you got to be very careful
about appending things to your array and
there's a number of reasons for that
one is run time because of the way the
numpy ray
is set up a lot of times you build your
data
and then push it into the numpy array
instead of continually adding on to
the array and then it also
usually it automatically generates a
copy for protecting your data
so there's a lot of reasons to be
careful about appending this way
but you can certainly do it and we can
just take our array we're going to
create a new array
array 1 and if we print array 1 and we
append 8 to it
you'll see 4 5 6 7 and then there's our
8 appended onto the end
and if you want to append something to
an array
you'd probably also want to whoops
array one let's try that again there we
go now we have the eight appended onto
the end
so you can see four five six seven eight
and then we pinned it another eight on
there
and if you're going to append something
you might want to
go ahead and insert instead of appending
it might be you need to keep a certain
order
and we can do the same thing we do our
array
and we're going to pin or insert
at the beginning and let's go ahead and
insert uh one two three
one two three and we go ahead and print
our array two
we run it and you can see one two three
a pin is inserted
at the beginning uh inserts a lot more
powerful and that you can put it
anywhere in the array we can move it to
the one spot
and there we go one two three we can do
a minus one just for fun and you'll see
it comes up
one two three and we're counting
backwards by one i imagine do a minus
0 and run this and it turns out that
minus 0 puts it back at the beginning
because that's why it registers a 0 just
takes a minus sign off
and just like we add numbers on we might
want to delete numbers
and so uh let's do an np dot delete
well let's let's keep it a little bit
make it a little easy here um
to watch we'll go ahead and create an
array three and we'll do np
delete and we're just working with array
2 and we want to do is delete 0 space
so if you look at this here's our array
2 our raid 2 starts with 1
and when we delete the space on here
and print that out we deleted the one
right out of there
and we can also do something like this
where we can do it as a slice
and we can do let's do one comma three
and if we run one comma three you'll see
we've deleted the one space
and the three space out which deleted
our two and four
now keep in mind when you're messing
with
adding lines and deleting lines
you have to be really careful because
there's a time element involved
as far as where the data is coming from
and it's really easy to delete the wrong
data and corrupt what you're working on
or to insert stuff where you don't want
it
so there's always a warning when we talk
about manipulating numpy arrays
and just like anything else we're doing
we'll create an
array c which equals we'll just do
our our numpy array that we just created
our number array 3
and we can do copy so you can make a
copy of it
maybe you want to protect your original
data or maybe you're making a mask
and so you copy the array and then the
new array make all these alterations and
change it from values to 0 to 1
to mask over the first one and of course
we if we do
array c since it equals a copy of
array 3 it's the same thing 1 3 5 6 7
eight
and now we're getting into uh combine
and split arrays
i end up doing a lot of this and i don't
know how many times i end up fiddling
with this and having
a mess so but but you do it a lot you
know you combine your arrays you split
them you might need one set of data for
one thing another set of data for the
other
so let's go ahead and create two arrays
array one or a two
and i want you to note in the
terminology we're going to look for is
concatenate and what that means is we're
going to take
um we'll call this a ray cat i like a
ray cat
there we go um our array cat our
concatenated array
we're taking array one and two and it's
very important to really pay attention
to your axes and your counts
i can't merge two arrays that have like
if their axes are messed up and i'm
merging on axis 0
it's going to give me an error and i'll
have to reshape them so you got to make
sure that whatever you're concatenating
together works
and what that means as you can see here
we have 1
2 3 4 one two three four
and then five six seven eight five six
seven eight along the zero axes
these each are four values um so it's a
two by four value
and if we go ahead and switch this to
one you can see how that flips it a
little bit so now we have one two three
four five six seven eight
it's interesting that we chose that one
if i did something like this
where this is now there we go
and we concatenate it run this and it
gives me an answer okay because i have
two
by two and i'm using axes one but if i
switch this to actually
zero where now it's got three and five
it gives me an error so you got to be
really careful on that
to make sure that you're whatever axes
you are putting together
that they match like i said this one
oops x is one
axis one has two entities and since
we're going on axes one or by row
you can see that it lets it merge it
right onto the end there
and you could imagine this if this was a
xy plot of value
or the x value going in and the
predicted y value coming out
and then you have another prediction and
you want to combine them this works
really easy for that
and we'll go back and let's just put
this back to where we had it
oops i forgot how many changes i made
there we go
i'll just put it oops i messed up in my
concatenation order here
[Music]
there we go
okay so you can see that we went through
the different concatenation
axis is really important when you're
doing your concatenation values on here
and we'll switch this back to one just
because i like the looks of that better
there we go
two rows now there are
other commands in here so we can do
cat v equals npv
v stack this is nothing more than your
concatenation
but instead we don't have to put the
axes in there
because it's v stands for vertical and
so if we print out
cat v and we run this
you can see we get the one two three
four one two three four and that would
be the same as making this axis zero for
vertical stack
and if you're going to have a vertical
stack you can also have an
h stack so if we change this
to from v stack to oops here we go
h stack and we'll just change this from
cat to cat
and i run this
it's the same as doing axes zero the
process is identical in the background
this is like a legacy setup your v stack
and your h stack
most people just use concatenate and
then put the axes in there
is under it's kind of data exploration
um and that'll make a little bit more
sense in just a moment
sometimes they call them set operations
but let's say we have an array
one two three four five six three
whatever it is uh
we generate a nice little array here and
what i want to go ahead and do
is find the unique values in that array
so maybe i'm generating what they call a
one hot
encoder and so these values then all
become
i need to know how long my bit array is
going to be
so each word how many how many each word
is represented by a number
and then i want to know just how many of
those words are in there if we're doing
word count very popular thing to do
and you can see here when we do unique
uh we have one two three four five
6. those are our unique values
some of the things we can do with the
unique values is we can also instead of
doing just unique
we can do uniques or unique values and
counts of each unique value
and this is very similar to what we just
did up here where we we're doing np
unique but we're going to add a little
bit more into there
and it's just part of the arguments in
this and we want to do return
counts equals true
so in instead of just returning the
unique values
uh we want to know how many of those
unique values are in each one
and we'll go ahead and print our uniques
and print our counts
when we run that uh you can see here
we have our unique value one two three
four five six just like we had before
and then there's two of the first of two
ones two twos two threes two fours one
five two sixes and so on
and you can go through and actually look
at that if you want to count them
but a quick way to find out your
distribution of different values
so you might want to know what how often
the word the is used versus the word
and if each word is represented as a
unique number
and along the set variables we might
want to know
um let me just put a note up here we're
going to start looking at
intersection and we might want to also
know
differentiation
and uh neither
so when we're whoops neighbor neither
um so what we're looking at now is we
want to know hey where do these two
arrays intersect and we have one two
three four five
three four five 6 7 we might want to
know what is common between the two
arrays
and so when we do that we have np
intersect and it's a 1d
array one dimensional array
and then we need to go ahead and put
array one array two
and if we run this we can see they
intersect at three
four 5 that's what they have common
and because we're going to go ahead and
go through these and look at a couple
different options let's change this from
intersect 1d and we'll do the same thing
we'll go ahead and print this
so we might want to know the
intersection uh where they have
commonalities
another unique word is union of 1d
so instead of intersect we want to know
all the values that are in
both of them so here's our union of 1d
when we run that
you can see we have one two three four
five six seven so that's all the
different values in there
and the last one of the last words we
have two more to go
as we want to know what the set
difference is
so that's where that you'll see if you
remember set we talked about that being
the
what they call these things so the set
difference
of a 1d array when we run that you can
see that one is only in one array and
two is only in one array
and if we want to know uh what's in
array one but not in array two
we might wanna know what is in array one
but not two and what's in two but not
one
and this would be the set x or one d on
here
uh so we have the four different options
here where we can do
an intersection what do they both have
in common uh we can do a union
what are all the unique values in both
arrays
we can see the difference what's in
array one but not
array two so set diff one d and then
set x or what is not in one
but is in two and what is in not in two
but in one
so we dug a lot in numpy because we were
talking um there's a lot of different
little
mathematical things going on in numpy a
lot of this can also be done in
pandas although usually the heavy
lifting is left for numpy because that's
what it's designed for
let's go ahead and open up another
python 3
setup in here and so we want to explore
what happens when you want to display
this this is where it starts getting in
my opinion a little fun
because you're actually playing with it
and you have something to show people
and we'll go ahead and rename this we're
going to call this pandas
and pie plot so pandas pie plot
just so we can remember for next time
and we want to go ahead and import the
necessary libraries
we're going to import pandas as pd now
remember this is a data frame
so we're talking rows and columns and
you'll see how
pandas work so nicely uh when you're
actually showing data to people
and then we're gonna have numpy in the
background numpy works with pandas
uh so a lot of times you just import
them by default
seaborn sits on top of the matplot
library
so sometimes we use the seaborn because
it kind of extends it's one of the
100 packages that extends the matplot
library probably the most commonly
used because it has a lot of built in
functionality
almost by default i usually just put
seaborne in there in case i need it
and of course we have matplot library as
pi plot
as plt and note we have as
pd as np as sns as plt
those are pretty standard so when you're
doing your imports i would probably keep
those just so other people can read your
code and it makes sense to them that's
pretty much a standard nowadays
and then we have the strange line here
it says
ambersign matplot library inline
that is for jupiter notebook only so if
you're running this
in a different package you'll have a
pop-up when it goes to display the
matplot library
you can with the most current version of
jupyter usually leave that out
and it will still display it right on
the page as we go and we'll see what
that looks like
and then we're going to go ahead and
just do the seaborn the sns.set
and we're going to set the color codes
equals true let them
just keep the default one so we don't
have to think about it too much
and we of course have to run this the
reason we run this
is because these values are all set if
we don't run this and i access one of
these
afterward it will crash
the cool thing about jupiter notebooks
is if you forgot to import one of these
you forgot to install it because you do
have to install this under your anaconda
setup or whatever setup you're in
you can flip over to anaconda and run
your install for these
and then just come back and run it you
don't have to close anything out
and we'll go ahead and paste this one in
here real quick we have car
equals pd dot read underscore csv
and then we have the actual path
this path of course will vary depending
on what you
are working with uh so it's wherever you
save the file at
and you can see here i have um like my
onedrive documents simply learn
python data analytic using python
slash car csv it's quite a long file
when we open that up what we get is we
get
a csv file and we have the make the
model the year
the engine fuel type engine horsepower
cylinders and so on and this is just a
comma separated file so each row is like
a row of data
think of it as a spreadsheet
and then each one is a column of data on
here and
as you can see right here it has the
make model so it has columns for a
header on here
now your pandas just does an excellent
job of
automatically pulling a lot of this in
so when you start seeing the pandas on
here
you realize that you are already like
halfway done with getting your data in
i just love pandas for that reason numpy
also has it you can load a csv directly
into numpy
but we're working with pandas and this
is where really gets cool
is i can come down here and i can print
remember our print statement we can
actually get rid of it
and we're just going to do car head
because it's going to print that out
the head is going to print the top
values of
that data file we just ran in and so you
can see right here
it does a nice printout it's all nice
and inline because we're in jupyter
notebook
i can scroll back and forth and look at
the different data
and just like we expected we have our
column and it brought the header right
in
one thing to note is the index it
automatically created an index 0 1 2 3 4
and so on
and we're just looking at the head so we
got 0 1 2 3 4.
you can change this you might want to
just look at the top two
we can run that there's our top two bmws
another thing we can do is instead of
head we can do tail
and look at the last three values that
are in that
data file and uh you can see right here
it
numbered them all the way up to eleven
thousand nine hundred and thirteen oh my
goodness they put a lot of data in this
file
i didn't even look to see how big the
file was so you can really
easily get through and view the
different data in here
when you're talking about big data
you almost never just print out car
in fact let's see what happens when we
do if we run this and we just run the
car
it's huge in fact it's so big that the
pandas automatically truncates it and
just does head plus tail
so you can see the two um so we really
don't want to look at the whole thing
i'm going to go back to we'll stick with
the head
displaying our data there we go so
there's a head of our data gives us a
quick look
to see what's actually in there i can
zoom out if we want so you can actually
get a better view
although we'll keep it zoomed in so you
can see the code i'm working on
and then from the data standpoint we
course want to look at
data types uh what's going on with our
data what does it look like
now this you know you show your when
you're talking to your shareholders
they like to see these nice easy to read
charts they look like a spreadsheet
so it's a nice way of displaying pieces
of the chart
we talk about the data types now we're
getting into
the data science side of it what are we
working with well we have
uh make model we have an integer 64 for
the year
engine fuel type is an object if we go
up here you can see that there
most of them are like you know it's a
set
manual rear wheel drive so they might be
very
limited number of types in there uh
and so forth and you'll it's either
going to be a float 64 an integer or an
object is the way it's going to read it
on here
and the next thing you're going to know
is like your columns
and since it loaded the columns
automatically we have here
the make the model the year the engine
the size all the way up to the
msrp
and just out of something you'll see
come up a lot
is whenever you're in pandas and you
type in dot values
it converts it from a pandas list to a
numpy array
and that's true of any of these so then
you end up in a numpy array so you'll
see a little switch in there in the way
that the
data is actually stored and that's true
of any of these
in this case we want car dot columns
we have a total list of your car columns
and like any good data
scientist we want to start looking at
analytical summary of the data set
what's going on with our data
so we can start trying to piecemeal it
together so we can do car
describe and then we'll do is we'll do
include
equals all so a nice panda command is to
describe your data
if you're working with r this should
start looking familiar
and we come down here and you can see
count there's a
make the model the year um how many of
each one
how many unique values of each one the
top value of each one what's most common
the frequency
the mean clearly on some of these it's
an object so really can't
tell you what the average is you know
it'd just be the top ones the average i
guess
the year what's the average year on
there all this stuff comes down here
your standard deviation
your minimum value your maximum value
what's in the lower quarter 50 mark
where's that line at
and what's in the upper 75 percent the
top 25
going into the max now this next part is
just cool
uh this is what we always wanted
computers to be back like in the 90s
instead of 5 000 lines of code to do
this maybe not 5 000.
all right i built my own plot library
back in 95
and the amount of code for doing a
simple plot
was i don't know probably about 100
lines of code
this is being done in one line of code
we have our car which is our pandas
we generated that it's our data frame
and we have dot
hist for histogram that is the power of
seaborn now it's still going to generate
a numpy
graph but seaborn sits on top and then
we can do the figure size
this is just so it fits nicely on the
paper on here and we do something simple
like this and you can see here where it
comes up and does say matplot library
and does subplots and everything
but we're looking at a histogram of all
the different
pieces in our database and we have our
engine cylinders
that's always a good one because you can
see like they have some that are they
had
a null on there so they came out as zero
um
maybe a couple maybe one of them had a
two cylinder engine away back when
four is a common uh six a little less
common and then you see the eight
cylinder
uh 12-cylinder engines well it's got to
be a speedster or something
uh but you can see right here just
breaks it down so now you have
uh how many cars with how many whatever
it is cylinders
horsepower and so on and it does a nice
job displaying it
you can see if you're working with your
uh um
you're going into your demo it's really
nice just to be able to type that in and
boom there it is it can see it all the
way across
and we might want to zero in and use
like a box plot and this time we'll go
ahead and call the
seaborn sns box plot and we're going to
go ahead and do
vehicle size in versus engine horsepower
xy plot
and the data comes from the car so if we
run this
we end up with a nice box plot you see
our mid-size
compact and large you can see the
variation there's our outlier showing up
there on the compact
that must be a high-end sports car a
large car might have a couple engines
and again we have all these outliers and
then your deviation on them
very powerful and quick way to zero in
on one small piece
of data and display it for people who
need to have it reduced to something
they can see
and look at and understand and that's
our seaborn box plot or
sns.box plot and then if we're going to
back out
and we want a quick look at what they
call pair plotting
we can run that and you can see with the
seaborn it just does all the work for
you
it takes just a moment for it to pull
the data in and compile it
and once it does it creates a nice grid
and this grid
if you look at this one space here which
is you might not be able to see the
small number it says engine horsepower
this is engine horsepower to the year it
was built
and it's just flipped so everything to
the right of the middle diagonal is just
the rotation of what's on the left and
as you expect
the engine horsepower gets bigger and
bigger and bigger
as time goes on so the the year it was
built the further up in the year the
more likely you are to have a heavy
horsepower engine
and you can quickly look at trends
with our pair plot coming up uh and look
how fast that was that was it took it a
couple
a moment to process but right away i get
a nice view of all these different
information which i can look at visually
in kind of
see how things group and look now if i
was doing a meeting
i probably wouldn't show all the data
one of the things i've learned over the
years is people myself included love to
show all our work you know we're taught
in school show all your work prove what
you know
the ceo doesn't want to see a huge uh
grid of
of graphs i guarantee it so we want to
do is we want to go ahead and drop
the stuff that might not be interested
in and we're gonna i'm not really a car
person
a guy in the back is obviously so you
have your engine fuel type we're gonna
drop that we're gonna drop
market category vehicle style popularity
number of doors
vehicle size and we have the axes in
here if you remember from numpy
we have to include that axis to make it
clear what we're working on that's also
true with pandas
and then we'll look at just what it
looks like from the head
and you can see that we dropped out
those categories and now we have the
make
model year and so forth and we took out
the engine fuel type market category etc
and this should look familiar to you now
when you start working with pandas
i just love pandas for this reason look
how easy it is it just displays it as a
nice
spreadsheet for you you can just look at
it and view it very easily
it's also the same kind of view you're
going to get if you're working in spark
or
pi spark which is python for spark
across big data
this is the kind of thing that they they
come up with this is why pandas is so
powerful
and we may look at this and decide we
don't like these
columns and so you can go in here
and we can actually rename the columns
simple command car equals car rename
columns equals
engine horsepower equals horsepower this
is just your standard
python dictionary so it just maps them
out
and you know instead of having like a
lengthy effect here we had
engine horsepower we just want
horsepower we don't need to know what's
the engine horsepower
engine cylinders we don't need to know
that it's for the engine because there's
only one thing we're describing if we're
talking about cars and that cylinders
and we'll go ahead and just run this and
again here's our car head and you can
see how that changed
we have model year in horsepower versus
model year engine horsepower engine
cylinders
and just cylinders again
we want to keep reducing this so it's
more and more readable
the more readable you get it the better
and of course we can also adjust the
size a little bit
so that when it prints out instead of
splitting it on two lines we get like a
single line we can do that also
that's just your control mouse up or
plus sign
you use in chrome that's a chrome
command
and if you remember from numpy we had
shape well pandas works the same way
we can look at the shape of the data so
we now have
11 914 rows and 10 columns
so you see some similarities because
pandas is built on numpy
and questions that come up just like you
did in numpy we might want to know
duplicate rows
and so we can do car and look at this
switch here
we're doing a selection this is a pandas
selection with the brackets
but we want to select it based on car
dot duplicated so how many duplicates on
there
so we're starting to look a little bit
different as far as how we access
some of the data in here this can be a
logical statement and we get the number
of duplicate rows we have 989 rows by 10
columns again
and this is one of those troubleshooting
things that we end up doing
a lot more than we really feel like we
should
we might go ahead and do like a car
count uh just to see how many rows we're
dealing with
and then right after that we might want
to go ahead and say hey
um let's drop duplicates so remember we
did all the duplicates on there so car
equals car
dot drop duplicates and then we can
print the head again
we'll just do car head here and you can
see the data on there
looks the same as before
uh and just note that we did car equals
car drop duplicates
there are commands in here where you can
do where it changes
the actual value and it works on some of
them and not on others depending on what
you're doing
but by default it always returns a copy
so when we
do this we're reassigning it to car and
you can see it's the same header but we
want to go ahead and do
count and see how the count changes
let's go ahead and run this
and you can see here instead of 11 914
we have 10
925 so we've removed
about a hundred cars that were
duplicated just slightly under 100 there
and then as we're prepping our data we
might want to know
car is null uh so it's going to count
the values of null and then we want to
sum that up
and when we do that we do the car is
null function dot sum
uh we end up with uh hp the horsepower
at 69 have null values and 30
have cylinders have no values now if you
don't put the sum at the end
it's just going to return a mask
with the true false of is it null or is
it not
by 0 and one so you're summing up the
ones underneath each column
and this of course then you have to
decide what you're going to do with the
null values there's a lot of different
options it might be that you need to put
in the average or means
maybe you want to put in the median
value there's a lot of different ways to
fill it
usually when you first start out with
the data a lot of them you just drop
your null values and you can see here
car.drop in a
which is equal to all and then we're
going to go ahead and count it and you
can see that we've dropped
almost another 100 values so from 10
1925
to 10 827 maybe 75 or so values
so we claim that this is really a big
part of cleaning data you need to know
how to get rid of your null values or at
least count them and what to do with
them
and of course if we go back to
counting our null values we should now
have
no no values there we go and you'll see
there's zero null values
i don't know how many times i've been
running a model that doesn't take
no values and it crashes and i just sit
there and look at it trying to get why
did that crash
it should have worked it's because i
forgot to remove the null values
so we've been jumping around a lot we're
going to go back to
finding outliers and let's go ahead and
bring that back into our seaborn
and if you remember we did a box plot
earlier this time we're going to do a
box plot
just on the price and you can see here
our price value and we have the
deviation with the two thinner bars on
each side of the main value
and then as we get up here we have all
these outliers in fact we have one way
out here that's
probably a really expensive high-end car
is what we're looking at
if you were doing fraud analysis
you would be jumping on all over these
outliers why are these deviation from
the standard what are these people doing
again this is probably like i said a
really high-end expensive car out here
that's what we're looking at
and we can also look at the box plot
for the horsepower and we'll put that in
down here
and run that and you can see again
here's our horsepower and it just
jumps and there's these really odd huge
muscle cars out here that are outliers
and we're going to jump into making this
a little bit more
as you start displaying your data or
your information to your shareholders
we're going to look at plotting a
histogram for the number of cars per
brand
and the first thing we want to go ahead
and do
is we have with our car and go back over
here here we go
uh we have our make value counts largest
plot
and we want to do a kind equals bar
figure size
10 5.
and right off the bat we jump up here
and we see chevrolet
it's going against what was it it's um
figure race station
the value counts and we want the largest
value so here's our value counts
and compared to what the different cars
are chevrolet puts out a lot of
different kinds of cars
i didn't realize that they made that
many cars or different types
and then for readability let's go ahead
and add a title
number of cars by make number of cars
and make
if you had looked at this the first time
he would have been like well what the
heck am i looking at
well we're looking at the number of cars
by make and then you can see here now
we're talking about the type of cars
and the different ones are put out lotus
i guess only had a few different kinds
of cars over there
very high-end cars and then
as uh doing data analytics and as a data
scientist one of the things
i am most interested in is the
relationship between
the variables so this is always a place
to start we want to know what's going on
with our variables and how they connect
with each other
so the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to go ahead and set a figure
size because we want to make sure
it fits our graph we'll just go ahead
and set this one
plot figure set to figure size 2010.
if you never use the matplot library
which is sitting behind seaborne
uh whatever is in the plt this is what's
loaded it's like a
canvas you're painting on so the second
you load that pi plot as plt
anything you do to that is affecting
everything on it
and then we want to go ahead since we're
using seaborn
we'll go ahead and create a variable c
for
relationships or correspondence and car
dot
c-o-r-r that's a correlation in
seaborne on top of pandas again
one line and you get the whole
correlation on there
and because we're working with seaborne
let's put it into a nice heat map
if you're not familiar with heat maps
that means we're just using color
as part of our setup so we have a nice
visual
and we can see here that the seaborne
connected to the pandas prints out a
nice chart
we'll talk a little bit about the color
here in a second it prints out a nice
chart this is a chart
i look at as a data scientist these are
the numbers i want to look at
and we'll just highlight one of them
here's cylinders
versus horsepower the closer to one the
higher the correlation so 0.788
pretty high correlation between the
number of cylinders and how heavy the
horsepower is
i'm betting if you looked at the year
versus horsepower
um we just look at that one here's year
and horsepower
0.314 not as so much but if you combine
them you don't actually add them
but if you combine them you'll start to
see an increase in horsepower per year
in cylinders you could probably get a
correlation there and just like 0.78
is a positive correlation you might
notice if we look at
cylinders and or let's look at
horsepower
and mileage so if we go here to
horsepower to mileage
you get a nice negative we'll do
cylinders that's a bigger number
with cylinders to the miles per gallon
it's a minus
0.6 so it's a negative correlation the
closer to minus one the more the
negative correlation is
and then the chart you would actually
show people is a nice
heat map this is all our colors and it's
just those numbers put into a heat map
the darker the color the higher the
correlation you can see
straight down the middle um obviously
the year correlates directly with the
air horsepower with horsepower and so on
that's why it's a one the closer the one
the higher the correlation between the
two pieces of data
this is a good introduction pandas goes
way beyond this
most the functionality in numpy since
panda sits on it
is also in pandas and then it even has
additional
features in it and we use seaborne
pretty extensively
sitting on top over our pie plot so keep
in mind that our
pie plot has a ton of other features in
it that we didn't even touch on in here
we couldn't even if you had a soul
course in it there's just so many things
hidden in there
depending on what your domain you're
working on but you can see here here's
our
seabourn and here's our matplot library
that's all our graphics that we did
and then the seaborn works really nicely
with the pandas
we really like that so that wraps up our
demo part for today
let's understand a case study from
walmart and how it uses data analytics
to grow its business and serve its
customers better
walmart is an american multinational
retail company
that has over 11 500 stores and 27
countries worldwide
and it has e-commerce websites in 10
different countries
it has more than 5900 retail units
operating outside the united
states with 55 banners in 26 countries
with more than
7 lakh associates serving more than 100
million customers every week
it has over 2.2 million employees around
the world and 1.5 million employees in
the united states alone
walmart's e-commerce branch alone
employs more than 3
000 technologies from silicon valley to
india
england and south america
more than 240 million customers shop at
walmart each week
online and at its banner stores
walmart.com
sees up to 100 million unique visitors a
month according to comscore
and is growing every year
walmart collects over 2.5 petabytes of
data
from 1 million customers every hour
that's really huge
now to make sense of all this
information walmart has created data
cafe
a state-of-the-art analytics hub located
within its bantonville
arkansas headquarters
here over 200 streams of internal and
external data including 40 petabytes of
recent transactional data can be modeled
manipulated and visualized teams from
any part of the business are invited to
bring their problems to the analytics
experts
and then see a solution appear before
the rise on the nerve center's touch
screen smart boards
walmart also constantly analyzes over
100 million keywords
to know what people near each store are
saying on social media
to understand the customer behavior on
what they like and dislike
walmart uses modern tools and
technologies to derive
business insights and improve customer
satisfaction some of these tools include
python sas nosql databases such as
cassandra and hadoop
now using all these technologies and
data analysis techniques
walmart can better manage its supply
chain optimize product assortment
personalize the shopping experience give
relevant product recommendations
and finally optimize and analyze
transportation lanes and routes
for its fleet of trucks
with that let's jump into our use case
demo
where we will predict the sales based on
advertising expenditure
using the linear regression model in r
the advertising expenditure has been
made via different mediums
such as radio television and newspaper
we will use the r programming software
to implement the demo
so why are well
r is a free and open source software
that can be downloaded from the
ran website it is easy to learn and use
our language is built specifically for
performing statistical analysis
data manipulation and data mining using
packages such as plier
deep plier tidier and lubricate
r supports data visualization with the
help of packages such as ggplot
google waste our color brewer leaflet
and gg map
and finally the r software can be used
in a wide range of analytical modeling
including
classical statistical tests linear and
non-linear modeling
data clustering time series analysis and
more
now let's have a look at our data that
we will be using for this demo
here is our advertising csv data set
which has four columns
you can see this tv ads expenditure
the next column is for radio ads then we
have the newspaper ads
and the last column is our target column
that is the sales
so the data set has
in total 200 rows
now to understand the data let me give
an example
so consider the second row so suppose
you spend around
230 on tv ads then
37.8 dollars on radio ads
and 69.2 dollars newspaper ads
you can expect to sell nearly 22 units
of a particular product
similarly if you are spending 44.5
dollars in tv advertising
39.3 dollars in radio ads and 45
dollars in newspaper ads you can sell
around 10 units
of certain item we will analyze this
data using linear regression
so linear regression is a supervised
learning algorithm
which means the data has labeled columns
and is used to predict numeric
continuous variables so our sales column
here is the target column and it has
continuous numeric variables now let me
go to the r studio and start with the
demo
so first i'll create a new file
then i'll select our script
the next step is to install all the
necessary packages that we need for this
demo
if you already have the packages
installed in your r studio you need not
do it again
you can just call these packages using
the library function and pass the
package names
so first i will install the dplyer
package
which is used for data manipulation i
will be using install.packages
function and i'll give the package name
so i'll type install dot packages if you
hit tab it will auto complete
then under quotations
i'll write d plier
i'm not going to run this because i
already have it installed in my
r studio the next step
i'll write i'll call this package using
library function
i'll give the package name deployer
i'll run this
then i'll install the broom package it
takes the messy output of
built-in functions in r such as linear
model or lm
then t test and turns them into a tidy
data frame
so i'll copy the above code i'll just
paste it again
i'll change it to broom
here also i'll change it to broom
i'll run this
okay then i'll be installing the ca
tools package
which will help us build our linear
regression model
replace the same code and i'll take ca
tools
and i'll call that using the library
function
i'll run this
now sometimes people face issues with
installing this particular package
if you also face this problem do visit
the r studio community page
now let me show it to you so
this is the r studio community page and
here
they have the solution you can just go
through this
two pages
all right
after this i will install the ggplot2
package which is a very popular
package in r for data visualization
i am not running installed packages
because i have already installed all
these packages before
if you have not so you have to run
install.packages first
and then call the library function
with that let's now load the data set
for this i will use the read.csv
function and provide the path location
where my data is located
followed by the dataset name and the
extension
i'll assign the loaded data set to a
variable
let me now go ahead and show you where
my data set is located
so here is my advertising csv data set
and this is the location
i'll copy this location
i'll move back to rstudio and
let me comment this line load the data
set
so i'll take a variable name
ads and then using
read.csv function
i'll pass the path location where the
data set is
present now one thing to
notice we have to change all the
backslash to
forward slash otherwise r won't accept
it
and finally i'll give the
data set name which is
advertising
dot csv
let me run it okay we have successfully
loaded our data set
now let us look at how our data set
looks like using the head function
so i'll give a comment display
the head of the data set
i'll be using the head function and i'll
pass
ads
run it so
you can see the head function has
displayed
the first six rows from the advertising
data set
let me now check the dimensions of the
data set so i'll use the dim function
it will give you the total rows and
columns present in the data set
give a comment check the
dimensions
i'll use the dim function and i'll pass
in
the ads variable
you can see it has given the number of
rows which is 200 and the total columns
which is
4.
now if you want to get a summary of the
data set you can use the summary
function
so i'll directly type in summary
and i'll give ads
let me expand this
so actually summary function gives you
information about a few statistics
for each of the columns so you can see
the minimum value for each column the
maximum value for each column
the mean the median first quartile and
the third quartile values
the first quartile or lower quartile is
the value that cuts off the first
25 percent of the data when it is sorted
in ascending order
the second quartile is the median which
has the value that cuts off the first 50
percent
and the third quartile or the upper
quartile is the value that cuts off the
first 75 percent of data
moving ahead let's do some data
visualization now
to visualize our data since our data has
only numeric values
using scatter plots would be the best
option
so we will visualize our sales against
each of the independent variables
for that i will use the plot function
and give
sales in my x-axis and the independent
variable names in the y-axis
let me now do that so i will give a
comment
data visualization
first i'll use the plot function
and then in x-axis
using the dollar symbol
i'll give sales then in the y-axis
i'll give my independent variable
you can see r is automatically giving
you the suggestions i'll select
tv then
i'll take type is equal to
under quotes i'll give p which stands
for points
and i'll take the color as
red
so you can see under plots we have our
scatter plot
if i zoom in you can see
the red dots are pretty much aligned in
one direction
which means if you are increasing the
expenditure on tv ads
the units sold are also increasing
equally
so the more you spend on tv ads the more
sales you can expect
close it now let's look at how sales
vary based on radio advertising
expenditure
i'll copy this
paste it and under y-axis i'll change it
to
radio
and i'll take the color now as
let's say blue color i'll run it
now foul to zoom in
now if you look at the blue dots it is
not that linear compared to
our previous graph you can see
there are a few data points like this
that show the sales were not good even
after spending decent money on radio ads
but still you can expect a decent amount
of sales if you are willing to spend on
radio advertising
close it
let's now look at how sales will vary
based on the newspaper advertising
expenditure
i'll change the radio to
newspaper column and this time i'll take
color as
green
i'll run it measurement
you can see the plots are very
haphazardly present
the data is completely non-linear and
there seems to be a low correlation
between the sales and newspaper
advertising expenditure
now if you want to look at these plots
at a time you can use the pairs function
so i'll type peers and then
pass in my variable name which is ads
i'll run it
let me zoom in so this is our plot
and you can see this has
all the visualizations so you can see
the
tv sales now you can see
the sales that were made with radio
expenditure
and with the newspaper expenditure as
well
i'll close it moving ahead
let's check the correlation between the
variables and see what inside we can get
we will use the core function or cor
function and build a correlation matrix
first let me go ahead and install the
core plot package
so i'll give a comment correlation
analysis
for this i will have to install
the core plot package
i have already got it installed then
i'll call this function using
library
i'll run it you can see code plot the
version has been uploaded
now i'll tell you how you can grab only
the numeric columns
now data only has numeric columns but
still let me tell you how you can do it
since correlations are based on numeric
columns only
this can be done using the s apply
function
so for that we have already installed
the dplyer library
i'll give a variable name as
num dot calls which is numeric columns
then i'll pass in the supply function
i'll give the adds variable and i'll
check
if the variable is numeric or not so
i'll use is dot
numeric
let me run it and now
let's display what's there in num dot
calls
you can see it says
tb it's true which means db has numeric
values even radio has numeric values
similarly for newspaper and sales also
then i'll use the correlation function
which is cor to display the correlations
between the variables
so i'll give my variable name as cor dot
data
and then i'll take the core function
pass in the ads variable and
i'll only filter out the
numeric columns so comma numeric columns
means
we need all the rows and the selected
columns
let me run it and now to display let me
call
cor dot data again
so this is our correlation output as you
can see
the correlation values are all above 0
which means there is a positive
correlation between the variables
and the change in one of the independent
variables will have a positive impact on
the sales numbers tv ads
have the maximum correlation with sales
and the value is around
0.78 then
there is radio advertising which has
correlation of about
0.57 with sales
and newspaper ads have the lowest
correlation compared to the other two
which is at 0.22
now you can also build a correlation
matrix using the correlation plot method
this will give you a visual
representation of the correlation
between the variables
so let's see how we can do that
i'll type core plot
and i'll give code.data
and i'll pass a method
as color
by zoom in you can see
this is our correlation matrix
on the right you can see the scale
so minus 1 is for negative correlation
then there's light red 0 which is almost
white color then there's light blue and
finally dark blue for the maximum
positive correlation
the diagonals are dark blue which
represents the same variables
as in rows and in columns so it's dark
blue
tv ads and radio ads have the next
highest correlation
why newspaper ads have the lowest
correlation with sales
with that let's jump into the most
important part of this analysis
which is building our regression model
first
we will look at a simple linear
regression model where we will take
one input variable that is tv ads
i'll be using the lm function or the
linear model function
to build the model so i'll give a
comment
simple linear
regression
i'll take a variable name as model
underscore
simple and then using
lm function i'll give my target variable
which is sales
and using tild
i'll give my independent variable which
is tb and
data as ads
i'll run it now that we have built our
linear regression model let's check the
summary
take summary function and i'll pass in
model underscore simple let me run it
now if i expand this
you can see our intercept estimate is
around 7.03 so when the tv
advertising budget is zero we can expect
sales to be around
seven thousand thirty or seven zero
three zero
also remember we are operating in units
of thousand
and for every thousand dollar increase
in the tv advertising
budget we can expect the average
increase in sales to be around
47 units
now the same summary can be checked
using the tidy function
present in the broom package so if i
call tidy and i'll give the
model name which is model underscore
simple
i'll run it so there you go this gives
us a tidy representation of the summary
figures
now let's build a regression model with
more than one input variable
so we'll build a multiple linear
regression
model
i'll take my variable name as model
underscore multiple this time
and i'll use the same lm function
i'll pass in the sales and
using till
i'll take all the column names stevie
then i'll use an addition operator and
i'll take in
newspaper
followed by the radio column
and then i'll take my data as ads
let's run it
i'll follow the same drill let me now
call the summary function over this
newly
created model so i'll write summary
and i'll select my model name as model
underscore multiple
let me run it
so the interpretation of our
coefficients is the same as in simple
linear regression model
first we see that our coefficients for
tv and radio advertising budget are
statistically significant
since our p value is less than 0.05
while the coefficient of newspaper is
not which is around 0.86
thus changes in the newspaper budget
does not
appear to have any relationship with
changes in sales
however for tv ads our coefficient
suggests that for every
thousand dollar increase in tb
advertising budget holding any other
predictors constant
we can expect an increase in sales of
45 units on average
similarly the radio coefficient suggests
that for every thousand dollar increase
in radio advertising holding all the
other predictors constant
we can expect an increase of 188 sales
units on an average
now you can also call the tidy function
over this multiple linear regression
model so let me do that i'll
call tidy and i'll pass in
model underscore multiple
you can see it has given the output
now you can also find the coefficients
of the model using another method
it's called the coefficient matrix
here is how you can do that so
take a variable name
and i'll use the summary function
i'll pass in model underscore multiple
and using the dollar symbol
i'll take the parameter as
coefficient
let me call c coefficient now
so these are the coefficients of
different variables
let me now show you another example of
how you can train a linear regression
model using the ca tools library
first i'll take a seed value a random
seed value of
say 101.
next i will split the data into training
and testing sets
i'll take 70 for training the data and
30 percent for testing the data
so i'll use a variable sample
then i'll call sample dot split
take ads and then
then i'll use another parameter called
split ratio
and i'll take the split ratio as point
seven which is seventy percent
i'll run it and then
i'll use another variable called train
and take the subset of the sample
pass in my ads variable and i'll select
sample
is equal to equal to true
similarly i'll take another variable
called test
i'll use my subset function
and given the same parameters
but this time i'll take sample is equal
to equal to
false which means the test sample data
set won't have any values that are
present in
train data set i'll run it
now we will use the same lm function to
create our model
so i'll take model
as my variable and assign it to
lm function
so i'll assign the linear model to the
model variable
i'll take sales as my target column
use the tilde followed by a dot
which means i'm taking all the variables
in terms of the independent variables
and then
i'll select my trained data set
with that let's check the summary as
well
so this is the summary of our newly
created model
now you can also check the residual
collector from the trained model using
the residuals function
let me go ahead and assign a variable
called res for residual
and i'll use the residuals function
pass in my model
then i'll convert the residuals into a
data frame
so i'll use the as dot data frame
function and pass in res
you can check the residuals so these are
the residual values
now it's time to make our predictions
using the test data set
i'll use the predict function for this
let me take another variable called
sales dot predictions
and i'll use the predict function
pass in my model followed by the test
data set now
run it then let me call
sales.prediction to display the values
as you can see
these are my predicted sales values
now let me combine this predictive sales
values to our original sales for the
test data
for that i'll use the c bind function
and pass the column names
i'll take another variable called
results
and use the c bind function
i'll take sales dot predictions
and i'll consider the sales column from
the test data
let me check the values now
so you have the predicted sales values
and the original values of sales but you
can see the columns don't have any name
assigned to them
so let me go ahead and assign the column
names using the call names function and
convert it into a data frame to make it
look better
so i'll use the call names
function and and pass in my results
variable
then i'll take a vector and
give the column names as spread for
predicted values
and let's say real for the original
values
let me run it now i'll convert this
into a data frame so i'll use as dot
data dot frame
and give my results variable
now if i display results
you can see go on top
you can see the columns have been
assigned successfully
so on the left you have the predicted
values and on the right you have the
real values
so we have successfully built our linear
regression model and predicted the sales
values
using linear regression in r
you can also go ahead and find the
accuracy of this model
to know how good your model is we won't
be covering that as part of this
tutorial
i'll leave it for you and encourage you
to do some research on how you can find
the accuracy of a linear regression
model
you will come across terms such as mean
squared error root mean squared error
and r squared value
if you are able to find the accuracy
please post the results in the comments
section
or if you face any issues with it please
post your queries we'll be happy to help
you
let us quickly hop on to our studio and
start performing the hands-on exercise
for data analysis
for this exercise we will use a data set
named as demographics which is in a dot
csv file type firstly let us load the
data set to rstudio
and we will locate this in a variable
named as
demo we also refer to this as a data
frame
and now you will notice that a variable
is created in an environment section
which is in the bottom right hand side
of the rstudio window and this
particular variable comprises of 510
observations or records with eight
variables
let us simply expand this particular
data frame
and have a quick check on the data
structure and
understand the data types this
particular data
frame includes variables such as
age marital income
the unit of income is dollar per day
education levels the car price
car category with several levels gender
and retired status
now let us view the top six records
of this particular data set for this
let's simply type
head of demo and the result is now
visible
in the console section if you're
interested to view
all the records then simply type view of
demo and this new window
will show you every single record that
is being
loaded to our studio
you may also simply apply the filters
and the filter section here
on individual categorical variables
now that we have loaded the data set and
also viewed
individual records let us focus on
creating
subsets of records by applying filters
on individual variables or multiple
variables
so firstly let us apply filter on gender
we will only retrieve the records where
gender is equal to female
and we will locate these records in a
variable named as
demo2
as you notice now in the environment
section the second variable is also
created that is demo
and this now is comprising of 250
observation which means the records are
filtered down
to only gender female
next let us see how to apply a filter on
income variable let us only retrieve the
records where
income is greater than hundred
let's view the result
as we say here all the records include
income
greater than 100.
now let us modify this query
and we will ensure that the retrieved
records
includes income greater than 100
and also specific variables are returned
let's say we only want to have
the first variable third variable and
the seventh variable
returned as the result
let's have a quick check so we only have
the first third and the seventh variable
returned
how about we only exclude
the variable six to eight
for this we include a prefix of minus
sign
and now let us see what is the result we
have the variables from
first to the fifth variable however we
don't have 6
7 and 8 variable
i hope it's clear so far
yes all right now let us see how can we
apply condition by including both the
variables
that is gender and income and then we
will filter the record
and create a subset of data
now let's view the result income
is greater than 100 and the gender
is only female
this is one way of creating subsets
however now let us see how to use the
subset command and create the subset
let's create a subset of records
by applying filter on marital status
and age we'll only retrieve records
where marital status
is equal to married and age is greater
than
35.
let's now view the result
so here we have the age greater than 35
and marathon status is married
let's use the same code and this time
we will retrieve selected variables
let's say variables ranging from
1 to 3.
let's have a quick check so there are
three variables
age is greater than 35 and marathon
status is
married
now let us see how to structure the data
by sorting the data frame
in ascending and in descending order
we will apply this order function on the
variable income
firstly let us see how to order income
variable in ascending order
let's do a quick check and here we have
income
in ascending order
now let's see how to modify the same
code and view
the records
with income in descending order
so we have now the income in descending
order how about
include two variables and sort the
variables accordingly
firstly we will sort the records
by ordering income and age in
ascending order
let's quickly view the result we have
income in ascending
and age as well in ascending
let's now modify this code this time
we will order income
in descending and age in ascending
let us view the result so the income is
in descending
and age is in ascending order
so hope this is clear on how to solve
the data frame by ascending and
descending order
per variable or by using multiple
variables
with this we will focus on learning
statistical analysis
how to perform statistical analysis on
individual variable
or multiple variable let's start by
understanding the data distribution of
variable income so that we identify
what is the minimum value of income what
is the maximum
what is the range what is median what is
the mean
and we will also focus on the quantile
distribution
which is also analyzed in a box plot
what is the minimum value
in the variable income
it's 9 and what is the maximum
so we have the maximum value now let us
see
what's the range
so the range shows you the result with
minimum and the maximum value how about
the difference of maximum
and the minimum now let us focus on
other summaries of data distribution
for this variable income let's identify
what is the mean value of income
the mean is 78.
let's also understand what is the
standard
deviation all right
so the standard deviation is one one two
dollar
let us see what is the variance the
variance should be
larger than the standard deviation
now let's say what is the median
absolute
deviation
as you notice here the median absolute
deviation value is lower than standard
deviation
why do we make this comparison from this
it is evident that
median absolute deviation is robust to
outliers
and standard deviation is
sensitive to outliers and also to the
change in the mean value
now let us understand the quantile
distribution
this is the same analysis that is
visualized in a box plot
ranging from zero percent to hundred
percent identifying the individual data
points
and we can also refer and compare this
to the min
the max and the median values
let us quickly see what is the median
value of
income
as you notice here the median is 45 as
well the 50th percent of quantile is 45
which means zero percent is minimum and
hundred percent is the maximum value
number of your question is what is 25
and 75 percent
this is again used for identifying the
range of interquartile
the interquartile range is nothing but
the difference of 75 percent
minus the 25 percent
let's quickly see what is the iqr
of income
the iqrf income is 58.
let us do a quick check five percent of
quantile is eighty six
and in five percent of quantile is
twenty eight
and the value is fifty eight which is
equal to the iqr
result
now that we have focused on the
statistical analysis
of the individual variables data
distribution
let us focus on the data visualization
in this we will have a pictorial
representation of analysis
to identify the outliers to see what is
the minimum
and where do we see the data densely
populated
and how is it scattered etcetera we will
begin with creating a histogram
now histogram can be used for univariate
analysis
which means in this scenario we will
consider
income variable and we will see how the
count
of income ranges gets distributed
in a histogram for this we will have to
install a package called as ggplot2
and also call this library ggplot
let us install the package
now let us call the library
all right and we are ready now to begin
with
visualization
for this we will use the geometric
object
histogram
on the data demo data frame
let me expand this window so that the
code is visible and also use
an aesthetic mapping for variable income
this will be helpful for filling colors
or filtrations etc
and only include 30 bins
with individual bin size width
of 100 which means there will be 100
incomes
in individual bins
let's quickly look at the distribution
of this histogram
as you notice there are couple of
outliers
the counts of these income range are
very
limited however we see the densely
populated
income ranges with higher counts
between 0 to 200
dollars per day this is also a way to
identify and segment
the customers based on their
income ranges now let us see how to
change the color
of this histogram and also the border of
the histogram
for this we will include some additional
options
such as fill
fill with blue color
and the border color is black
now as you notice here the executed code
provides
us the histogram with blue color bars
and
black color border lines now we will
focus on creating a faceted grid
face and grid is also an aesthetic
mapping object
we will see how to enable the multiple
histograms
across the marital status and the
genders
so that we identify how the income is
distributed
for individual marital status as well
the genders
let's zoom this view and have a look at
it
as you notice here there are some
interesting outliers here in the data
distribution
female unmarried drawing higher income
and male unmarried and married also
drawing higher income
as compared to the females
whereas if you notice that the female
unmarried is drawing much higher income
than the male
this may also be very much related to
the age
now let us see how to create a stacked
histogram when i say a stacked histogram
i mean instead of filling the color
we will fill the gender so that there is
a stack
within the histogram
so as you notice here i have made couple
of changes
i have included fill equal to gender
within the aesthetic mapping
now let us look at this histogram as you
see here
the gender is filled in the histogram
hence we have
stacked distribution of female and the
male
now let us focus on creating a bar chart
with education versus
income where we can identify the
education
levels and the income ranges for these
education levels
as you notice here we are going to
create a visualization
where we have the aggregation in form of
mean and the geometric object used here
is bar plot
now let's zoom this view and understand
which education level have higher
average income
so as we see here the blue color bar is
the post
undergraduate degree which means this
education
level draws higher average income
as compared to other education
levels now let's create a histogram
where we will see car price and the
number of cars for
individual category
let's look at this visualization
this visualization provides some
interesting insight
just by looking at the distribution of
the car prices
and the counts of the cars at the car
category
economy and even the luxury luxury car
category
or car price is pretty much distributed
whereas economy car category is dense
which means that we could also
look back into the income and age
variables and
try to figure out further more insights
and then
segment the customers for further
targeting of these customers
now what happens if we simply change
this bin width to 30.
as you observe here changing the bin
width or increasing the bin width
will also reduce the number of bins
now we only have four bins here
and the car category is filled that is
what we have enabled within the
aesthetic mapping
and we see some more interesting insight
as you look at the standard and the
luxury car category
the car prices are pretty much
overlapping
for the car category luxury and standard
this could be the starting car price of
the luxury brands
now let us create a clustered
bar chart
let's look at this visualization
in this visualization as you observe
though we have enabled fill equal to
gender in the aesthetic mapping
we do not have the view in stacked form
but we have the bars
one besides the other it is also because
we have enabled a position called as
position equal to dodge
in the code now what is the inside that
we can draw from this visualization
as you see post graduate degree
with female gender is drawing
higher average income as compared to any
other
education level
now let us see how to create a box plot
for variable income across the genders
so the box plot can be enabled if there
is a bivariate analysis to be performed
on a continuous variable and a
categorical variable
or multiple categorical variables with a
continuous variable
now let's look at this visualization
what does this say we have data
distribution
of income for individual genders that is
for female and the male
and we also notice outliers here
anything above this whisker is
considered to be outliers
it might make more sense if we also
include some coloring for these outliers
maybe also enable shape
now we have colored the outliers and
it's colored
orange let's see if we can also enable
the shapes
and now we have here the outlier color
as well the shape enabled
now let us see how to enable a violin
plot
what is the utility of violin plot with
the box plot we understand
the analysis and the distribution of the
data points
is to identify the outliers to know what
is the minimum value what is the max
what is the median and what are the
outliers
but what is the purpose of a violin plot
let us have a quick
check
as you observe there is some
concentration of data points in the
bottom
of every car category
however the concentration is higher for
standard car category as compared to
economy
and the luxury now this is an
interesting insight
that you wouldn't have come across in
box plot
the box plot is a very good
representation for identifying outliers
however violin plot will help you focus
on the nuances
which is not captured by the box plot
we can also simply combine the box plot
and the violin plot
together simply include this jaw
object
let's zoom this and now you have a
representation of
box plot and the violin plot
both combined in a single visualization
interestingly you notice the outliers as
well the concentration in the bottom
of this violin plot so this could be
some interesting insights that you draw
and focus on these data points and
understand what exactly
is happening there
now let's focus on the density plot that
is density estimate
of the histograms rather than just
viewing the
frequencies
now we see the frequency in the y-axis
across the income distributions
how about enabling the probability as
true
so that we enable the density instead of
the frequency
so now we have the density in the y axis
and in the x
axis we still have the income
distribution
this is the way of also adding a line
plot
which is a density plot on the histogram
now as you observe here the density plot
is
not in the same level as the bar
so let us adjust this line
for this we will include adjust
let's say equal to 3 and now let us see
how the visualization appears now the
density plot
is on the same level as the bar
now let us see how to create a cross
table
for car category
and gender for this let us call the
library
descr now let us create
the visualization enabling cross
table for car category
and gender
let's look at the result in console
as you see here now we see the counts of
the gender for individual car category
the values over here represents that
there are
67 females falling within the car
category economy
and 80 males within the car category
economy
and for luxury we see that the count of
female is higher than the male
as well the proportions now how do you
understand what proportions are
presented here
we may simply turn off some of the
proportions like the t-test the
chi-square etc
let us see how to enable that
now let's look at the result this looks
better
now that we have the counts the female
counts and the male counts across
individual car category we also see the
percentages
rather than just looking at the absolute
value so there are 45.6 percentage of
female
within the car category economy and 54.4
percentage of mail
within the car category economy
similarly across
rest of the car categories this kind of
cross table
or a contingency table is also helpful
when you want to analyze the different
categorical variables
and identify the counts or the
proportions
now let us see how to use a scatter plot
of age versus income
scatter plot is a visualization used for
bivariate analysis
when you want to perform some analysis
between two continuous variable
at a data point level rather than
performing the analysis at an aggregated
level
such as sum or main
and now we have a scatter plot of age
versus the income
age in the x-axis and income in the
y-axis
though we do not see any kind of a
positive correlation or a negative
correlation
but we still see some interesting
insights over here
some of the data points are pretty much
scattered and much away from densely
populated data points
i hope the learning has been informative
and interesting so far
we have covered the concepts of data
analytics
as well we have performed some hands-on
doing some statistical analysis
and also creating interesting
visualization
now we have shruti who will tell us the
top 10 data analysis
tools and help us understand data
analytics jobs resume
salary career skills roles and
responsibilities
finally she will help you learn the
difference between a data scientist and
a data analyst
over to sruti to achieve the goals of
data analysis we use a number of data
analysis tools
companies rely on these tools to gather
and transform their data
into meaningful insights so which tool
should you choose to analyze your data
which tool should you learn if you want
to make a career in this field
we will answer that in this session
after extensive research we have come up
with these top 10 data analysis tools
here we will look at the features of
each of these tools and the companies
using them
so let's start off
at number 10 we have microsoft excel all
of us would have used microsoft excel at
some point right
it is easy to use and one of the best
tools for data analysis
developed by microsoft excel is
basically a spreadsheet program
using excel you can create grids of
numbers text and formulae
it is one of the widely used tools be it
in a small or
large setup the interface of microsoft
excel looks like this
let's now move on to the features of
excel
firstly excel works with almost every
other piece of software in office
we can easily add excel spreadsheets to
word documents and powerpoint
presentations to create more visually
appealing reports or presentations
the windows version of excel supports
programming through microsoft's visual
basic for applications vba
programming with vba allows spreadsheet
manipulation that is difficult with
standard spreadsheet techniques
in addition to this the user can
automate tasks such as formatting or
data organization in vba
one of the biggest benefits of excel is
its ability to organize
large amounts of data into orderly
logical spreadsheets and charts
by doing so it's a lot easier to analyze
data especially while creating graphs
and other visual data representations
the visualization can be generated from
specified group of cells
those were few of the features of
microsoft excel
let's now have a look at the companies
using it most of the organizations today
use
excel few of them that use it for
analysis are the uk based company ernest
and young
then we have urban pro wipro and amazon
moving on to our next data analysis tool
at number 9 we have rapidminer
a data science software platform
rapidminer provides an integrated
environment for data preparation
analysis machine learning and deep
learning
it is used in almost every business and
commercial sector
rapidminer also supports all the steps
of the machine learning process
seen on your screens is the interface of
rapidminer
moving on to the features of rapidminer
firstly it offers the ability to drag
and drop
it is very convenient to just drag drop
some columns as you are exploring a data
set and working on some analysis
rapidminer allows the usage of any data
and it also gives an opportunity to
create
models which are used as a basis for
decision making and formulation of
strategies
it has data exploration features such as
graphs descriptive statistics and
visualization which allows users to get
valuable insights
it also has more than 1500 operators for
every data transformation
and analysis task
let's now have a look at the companies
using rapidminer
we have the caribbean airline leeward
islands air transport
next we have the united health group the
american online payment company paypal
and the austrian telecom company
mobilecom so that was all about
rapidminer
now let's see which tool we have at
number eight
we have talent at number eight talent is
an open source software platform which
offers data integration and management
it specializes in big data integration
talent is available both in
open source and premium versions it is
one of the best tools for cloud
computing and big data integration
the interface of talent is as seen on
your screens
moving on to the features of talent
firstly
automation is one of the great boons
talent offers
it even maintains the tasks for the
users
this helps with quick deployment and
development
it also offers open source tools talon
lets you download these tools for free
the development costs reduce
significantly as the processes gradually
speed up
talent provides a unified platform it
allows you to integrate with many
databases
sas and other technologies with the help
of the data integration platform
you can build flat files relational
databases and cloud apps 10 times faster
those were the features of talon the
companies using talent are
air france l'oreal cab gemini and the
american multinational pisa restaurant
chain dominos
next on the list at seven we have nine
constance information minor on nime is a
free and open source data analytics
reporting and integration platform
it can integrate various components for
machine learning and data mining
through its modular data pipelining
concept nime has been used in
pharmaceutical research
and other areas like crm customer data
analysis
business intelligence text mining and
financial data analysis
here is how the interface of nime
application looks like
now coming to the 9 features 9 provides
an interactive graphical user interface
to create visual workflows using the
drag-and-drop feature
use of jdbc allows assembly of nodes
blending different data sources
including pre-processing such as etl
that is extraction transformation
loading
for modeling data analysis and
visualization with minimal programming
it supports multi-threaded in-memory
data processing
9 allows users to visually create data
flows
selectively execute some or all analysis
steps and
later inspect the results models and
interactive views
nimeserver automates workflow execution
and supports
team-based collaboration 9 integrates
various other open source projects such
as machine learning algorithms from
becca
h2o keras spark and our project
9 allows analysis of 300 million custom
addresses
20 million cell images and 10 million
molecular structures
some of the companies hiring for nime
are united health group
asml fractal analytics atos and lego
group
let's now move on to the next tool we
have sas at number six
sas facilitates analysis reporting and
predictive modeling with the help of
powerful visualizations and dashboards
in sas data is extracted and categorized
which helps in identifying and analyzing
data patterns
as you can see on your screens this is
how the interface looks like
moving on to the features of sas
using sas better analysis of data is
achieved by using
automatic code generation as sql
sas allows you to access through
microsoft office by letting you create
reports using it and by distributing
them
through it sas helps with an easy
understanding of complex data and allows
you to create
interactive dashboards and reports
let's now have a look at the companies
using sas we have companies like genpak
iq wear accenture and ibm to name a few
that was all about sas so for all those
who joined in late let me just quickly
repeat our list
at number 10 we have microsoft excel
then at number nine we have rapidminer
at number eight we have talent at number
seven we have nine
and at number six we have sas so far do
you all agree with this list
let us know in the comment section below
let's now move on to the next five tools
in our list
so at number five we have both r and
python
yes we have two of them in the fifth
position
r is a programming language which is
used for analysis as well
it has traditionally been used in
academics and research
python is a high level programming
language which has a python data
analysis library
it is used for everything starting from
importing data from excel spreadsheets
to processing them for analysis
this is the interface of r
next up is the interface of the python
jupyter notebook
let's now move on to the features of
both r and python
when it comes to the availability of r
and python it is very easy
both r and python are completely free
hence it can be used without any license
r used to compute everything in memory
and hence the computations were limited
but now it has changed both r and python
have options for parallel computations
and good data handling capabilities
as mentioned earlier as both r and
python are open in nature all the latest
features are available without any delay
moving on to the companies using r we
have uber
google facebook to name a few python is
used by many companies
again to name a few we have amazon
google and the american photo and video
sharing social networking service
instagram
that was all about rn python
at number four we have apache spark
apache spark is an open source engine
developed specifically for handling
large scale data processing and
analytics
spark offers the ability to access data
in a variety of sources
including hadoop distributed file system
htfs
openstack swift amazon s3 and cassandra
it allows you to store and process data
in real time across various clusters of
computers using simple programming
constructs apache spark is designed to
accelerate analytics on hadoop while
providing a complete suite of
complementary tools
that include a fully featured machine
learning library a graph processing
engine
and stream processing so this is how the
interface of apache spark looks like
now let's look at the important features
of apache spark
spark stores data in the ram hence it
can access the data quickly and
accelerate the speed of analytics
spark helps to run an application in a
hadoop cluster up to 100 times faster in
memory and 10 times faster when running
on disk
it supports multiple languages and
allows the developers to write
applications in java scala r or python
spark comes up with 80 high level
operators for interactive querying
spark code for batch processing joins
stream against historical data or run ad
hoc queries on stream state
analytics can be performed better as
spark has a rich set of sql queries
machine learning algorithms complex
analytics etc
apache spark provides fault tolerance
through spark rdd spark resilient
distributed data sets are designed to
handle the failure of
any worker node in the cluster thus it
ensures that the loss of data reduces to
zero
conviva netflix iqea lockheed martin
and ebay are some of the companies that
use apache spark on a daily basis
at number three we have another
important growing data analysis tool
that is click
view qlikview software is a product of
click for business intelligence and data
visualization
qlikview is a business discovery
platform that provides
self-service bi for all business users
and organizations
with qlikview you can analyze data and
use your data discoveries to support
decision making
clickview is a leading business
intelligence and analytics
platform in gartner magic quadrant
on the screen you can see how the
interface of qlikview looks like
now talking about its features clickview
provides interactive guided analytics
with in-memory storage technology
during the process of data discovery and
interpretation of collected data
the qlikview software helps the user by
suggesting possible interpretations
qlikview uses a new patent in memory
architecture for data storage
all the data from the different sources
is loaded in the ram of the system and
it is ready to be retrieved from there
it has the capability of efficient
social and mobile data discovery
social data discovery offers to share
individual data insights within groups
or out of it
a user can add annotations as an
addition to someone else's insights on a
particular data report
qlikview supports mobile data discovery
within an html5 enabled touch feature
which lets the user search the data
and conduct data discovery interactively
and explore
other server based applications
qlikview performs olap and etl features
to perform analytical operations
extract data from multiple sources
transform it for usage and load it to a
data warehouse
the companies that can help you start
your career in qlikview are
mercedes-benz cab gemini citibank
cognizant and accenture to name a few
at number 2 we have power bi
power bi is a business analytic solution
that lets you visualize your data
and share insights across your
organization or embed them in your apple
website
it can connect to hundreds of data
sources and bring your data to life with
live dashboards and reports
power bi is the collective name for a
combination of cloud-based apps and
services that help organizations collate
manage and analyze data from a variety
of sources
through a user-friendly interface
bi is built on the foundation of
microsoft excel and has several
components such as windows desktop
application called power bi desktop
and online software as a service called
power bi service
mobile power bi apps available on
windows phones and tablets
as well as for ios and android devices
here is how the power bi interface looks
like as you can see there is a visually
interactive sales report with different
charts and graphs
moving on to the features of power bi it
has an easy drag and drop functionality
with features that make data visually
appealing you can create reports without
having the knowledge of any programming
language
power bi helps users see not only what's
happened in the past and what's
happening in the present
but also what might happen in the future
it offers a wide range of detailed and
attractive visualizations to create
reports and dashboards
you can select several charts and graphs
from the visualization pane
power bi has machine learning
capabilities with which it can spot
patterns in data and use those patterns
to make informed predictions and run
what-if scenarios
power bi supports multiple data sources
such as excel
tech csv oracle sql server pdf and xml
files
the platform integrates with other
popular business management tools like
sharepoint office 365 and dynamics 365
as well as other non-microsoft products
like spark
hadoop google analytics sap sales force
and mailchimp
some of the companies using power bi are
adobe axa
carlsberg capgemini and nestle
moving on to the next tool so any
guesses as to what we have at number one
you can comment in the chat section
below
finally on the top of the pyramid we
have tableau
gartner's magic quadrant of 2020
classified tableau as a leader in
business intelligence and data analysis
tableau interactive data visualization
software company was founded in jan 2003
in mountain view california
tableau is a data visualization software
that is used for data science and
business intelligence
it can create a wide range of different
visualization
to interactively present the data and
showcase insights
the important products of tableau are
tableau desktop tableau public tableau
server
tableau online and tableau reader
this is how the interface of tableau
desktop looks like
now coming to the features of tableau
data analysis is very fast with tableau
and the visualizations created
are in the form of dashboards and
worksheets tableau delivers interactive
dashboards that support insights on the
fly
it can translate queries to
visualizations and
import all ranges and sizes of data
writing simple sql queries can help
join multiple datasets and then build
reports out of it
you can create transparent filters
parameters and highlighters
tableau allows you to ask questions spot
trends and identify opportunities
with the help of tableau online you can
connect with cloud databases amazon
redshift
and google bigquery the companies using
tableau are deloitte
adobe cisco linkedin and the american
e-commerce giant amazon to name a few
and there you go those are the top 10
data analysis tools
hello everyone we have an interesting
topic for today
and that is data analytics jobs career
and salary
i will run you through the top 6 data
analytics job roles
so before i dive deep into the various
job rules let's quickly understand how
important a career in data analytics
is and what the future holds for
professionals in this domain
let's take a look at the growth of data
so back in the early 2000s there was
relatively less data generated
but with a rapid rise in technologies
and with the increase in the number of
various social media platforms and
multinational companies across the globe
the generation of data has increased by
leaps and bounds
did you know that according to the idc
the total volume of data is expected to
reach 175 zettabytes in 2025
now that's a lot of data let's take a
look at how organizations leverage all
of this data
as you know there are zillions of
companies across the world
these companies generate loads of data
on a daily basis
when i say data here it simply refers to
business information customer data
customer feedback product innovations
sales reports and profit loss reports to
name a few
companies utilize all of this data in a
wise way
they use all of this information to make
crucial decisions that can either hamper
or boost their businesses
you might have heard of the term data is
the new oil
well it definitely is but only if
organizations analyze all the available
data very well
then this oil is definitely valuable
and for that we have data analytics
organizations take the help of data
analytics to convert the available raw
data into meaningful insights
so what is data analytics technically
you can say it is a process wherein data
is collected from
various sources then cleaned which
involves removing
irrelevant information and then finally
transformed into some meaningful
information that can be interpreted
by humans various technologies tools and
frameworks are used in the analysis
process
as you might have heard of the term data
never sleeps
well it surely doesn't every millisecond
some of the other data is generated
and this is a constant process this
process is only going to increase in the
near future with the advent of newer
technologies
the data analytics domain holds
paramount importance in every sector
companies want to leverage on all the
generated big data
and boost their businesses they need
professionals who can play with data and
convert them into crucial insights
organizations are constantly on the
lookout for such candidates
and this opportunity will only increase
as data is only going to grow
every second so if you want to start
your career in this field or if you want
to switch your job role into a role in
the data analytics domain
then we have a set of job profiles that
you can look at
we will look into six job roles in the
data analytics field and learn what each
job role is all about
the responsibilities of a professional
working in that particular role
the skills required to get that
particular job the average annual salary
of a professional working in that troll
and finally the company is hiring for
that role so let's start off
first we have the job role of a data
analyst
a data analyst is a person who collects
processes
and performs statistical analysis of
large data sets
every business generates and collects
data be it marketing research
sales figures logistics or
transportation costs
a data analyst will take this data and
figure out a variety of measures
such as how to price new materials how
to reduce transportation costs
or how to deal with issues that cost the
company money
they deal with data handling data
modeling and reporting
now talking about their responsibilities
data
and lists recognize and understand the
organization's goal
they collaborate with different team
members such as programmers business
analysts
engineers and data scientists to
identify
opportunities for solving business
problems
data analysts write complex sql queries
scripts and store procedures to gather
and
extract information from multiple
databases
they filter and clean data using
different modern tools and techniques
and make it ready for analysis
they also perform data mining from
primary and secondary data sources
data analysts identify analyze and
interpret trends in complex data sets
this is done using statistical tools
such as r
and sas another key responsibility of a
data analyst is to create
summary reports and build various data
visualizations for decision making and
presenting it to the stakeholders
next let us discuss the important skills
that you need to know to become a data
analyst
firstly you should have a bachelor's
degree in computer science or
information technology
a master's degree in computer
applications or statistics is also
preferable
you must have a good understanding of
programming languages like
r python javascript and also understand
sql
in addition to that it is beneficial if
you have hands-on experience with
statistical and data analytics tools
such as sas minor microsoft excel and
ssas
basic understanding of machine learning
and its algorithms would be an advantage
acquaint yourself with descriptive
predictive prescriptive
and inferential statistics most
importantly you need to have a good
working knowledge of various data
visualization software
along with presentation skills this will
help you pitch in your ideas and view
viewpoints to the clients and
stakeholders better
now talking about their salaries a data
analyst earns nearly 5 lakhs 23
000 rupees per annum in india while in
the united states they earn around
four 62 three dollars per annum
let's now look at a few of the companies
hiring data analysts
so as you can see we have the american
e-commerce joint amazon then we have
microsoft
the american online payment company
paypal then we have walmart
bloomberg and capital one so that was
all about data analyst
the next job role is of a business
analyst
business analysts help guide businesses
in improving products
services and software through
data-driven solutions
they are responsible for bridging the
gap between it
and business using data analytics to
evaluate processes
determine requirements and deliver
data-driven recommendations
and reports to executives and
stakeholders
business analysts are responsible for
creating new models that
support business decisions and come up
with initiatives and strategies to
optimize
costs now let us look at the various
responsibilities of a business analyst
business analysts have a good
understanding of the requirements for
business
their vital role is to work in
accordance with relevant project
stakeholders to understand their
requirements and translate them into
details
which the developers can understand
they frequently interact with developers
and come up with a plan to design the
layout of a software application
they also run meetings with stakeholders
and other authorities
they engage with business leaders and
users to understand how data driven
changes
to products services software and
hardware can improve efficiencies and
add value
they ensure that the project is running
smoothly as per the requirements and the
design planned
through user acceptance and validation
testing
they make sure all the features are
being incorporated into the application
bas rely on different software to write
documentation
and design visualization to explain all
the findings
it is extremely critical for any ba to
effectively document the findings where
each requirement of the client is
mentioned in detail
now let us look at the skills required
for a ba
a bachelor's degree in the field of
science engineering or statistics or any
related domain will suffice
knowledge of programming languages such
as python and java is beneficial
you should be really good at writing
complex sql queries and you should also
have knowledge of various business
process models
along with knowledge of programming
languages ideas about statistical
analysis and predictive modelling is
necessary
decision making strong analytical and
problem solving skills are necessary to
solve
software and business issues you also
need to have excellent presentation and
communication skills
both oral and written
moving on to their salary a business
analyst is expected to earn around seven
lakh rupees per annum in india
in the us they earn nearly sixty eight
thousand three forty six dollars per
annum
iqea dell philips honeywell the famous
american messaging platform whatsapp
the uk based company ernest and young
are few of the companies hiring for
business analysts
up next we have the job role of a
database administrator
a database administrator is a
specialized computer systems
administrator
who maintains a successful database
environment by directing or performing
all related activities to keep the
organization's data secure
they are responsible for storing
organizing and retrieving data from
several databases and data warehouses
their top responsibility is to maintain
data integrity
this means that database administrator
will ensure that the data is secure from
unauthorized access
moving on to their responsibilities a
database administrator develops
designs and maintains a database to
ensure that the data in it
is properly stored organized and managed
well
they maintain data integrity by avoiding
unauthorized access and they keep
databases up to date they run tests and
modify the existing databases to ensure
that they operate reliably
they also inform end users of changes in
databases and train them to utilize
systems
they need to cooperate with programmers
data analysts and the it staffs to
ensure smooth running and maintenance of
databases
database administrators are responsible
for taking system backups in case of
power outages and other disasters
so they should have an efficient
disaster recovery plan
now let's have a look at their skills to
become a database administrator you
should have a bachelor's degree in
computer science or information
technology
knowledge of programming languages such
as python java and scala
is important you need to carry at least
three to five years of experience in
data management
you need to have an understanding of
different databases such as oracle db
mongodb mysql server and posgres sql
also they should have an idea about
database design and writing
sql queries finally you need to have a
good understanding of operating systems
such as windows mac os
and linux along with storage
technologies
talking about their salary a database
administrator in india can earn up to 4
lakh 97
000 rupees per annum in the us they earn
around 78 000
per annum let's have a look at the
companies hiring for database
administrators
so as you see here we have bookmyshow
oracle
the american m c intel amazon robert
half
and the new york times to name a few
fourth in the list of job roles we have
data engineer
a data engineer is someone who is
involved in preparing data for
analytical and operational uses
a data engineer transforms data into
useful format for analysis
they build and test scalable big data
ecosystems for businesses
a data engineer is an intermediary
between a data analyst and a data
scientist
now let's jump into their
responsibilities
data engineers develop test and maintain
architectures
they are responsible for managing
optimizing and monitoring data retrieval
storage and distribution throughout the
organization
they discover opportunities for data
acquisition find trends in data sets and
develop
algorithms to help make raw data more
useful to the enterprise
data engineers build large data
warehouses using etl for storing and
retrieving data
they also recommend ways to improve data
quality and efficiency along with
building algorithms to help
give easier access to raw data
data engineers often work with big data
and submit their reports to data
scientists for analysis purpose
they need to recommend and sometimes
implement ways to improve data
reliability efficiency and quality
moving on to the skills of a data
engineer
a data engineer should hold a bachelor's
degree in computer science or
information technology they should have
good hands-on experience with python r
and java
also data engineers should be
well-versed with big data technologies
such as hadoop apache spark
scala cassandra and mongodb data
warehousing
and detail experience are essential to
this position along with
in-depth knowledge of sql and other
database solutions
basic knowledge of statistical analysis
will be an advantage
along with idea about operating systems
here is what a data engineer can earn so
in india a data engineer can earn up to
eight lakhs eighty-five thousand rupees
per annum
while they can earn around hundred and
three thousand dollars a year in the usa
we have cab gemini shutterstock the
american provider of stock photography
spotify accenture genpak and facebook
hiring data engineers
the next exciting job role is of a data
scientist
a data scientist is a professional who
uses statistical methods
data analysis techniques machine
learning and related concepts in order
to
understand and analyze data to draw
business conclusions
they make sense to messy and
unstructured data and bring
value out of it they employ techniques
and theories drawn from many fields
within the context of mathematics
statistics
computer science and information science
a data scientist understands the
challenges in business and comes up with
the best solutions
using modern tools and techniques to
analyze visualize
and build prediction models to make
business decisions
let us now look at their
responsibilities in the industries
data scientists clean process and
manipulate data using several data
analytics tools
they perform ad hoc data mining collect
large sets of structured
and unstructured data from disparate
sources
they design and evaluate advanced
statistical models to work on big data
they also create automated anomaly
detection systems and keep constant
track of their performance
data scientists interpret the analysis
of big data to discover solutions and
opportunities a data scientist takes
input from data analysts
and engineers to formulate the results
they use visualization packages and
tools to create reports and dashboards
for relevant stakeholders
they also adopt new business models and
approaches
apart from this they regularly build
predictive models and machine learning
algorithms
now moving on to the skills of a data
scientist
a bachelor's degree in computer science
or information technology will be fine
but a master's degree in the field of
data science will hold a major advantage
you also need to have a good experience
in the analytics domain
you should be proficient in programming
languages such as python
java and c plus plus knowledge of pearl
will also be an advantage
familiarity with apache hive pig and
apache spark is
necessary along with the knowledge of
hadoop
in addition to knowing programming
languages you also need to know
sql machine learning and deep learning
data visualization and bi skills are
necessary for creating reports and
dashboards
you should also be able to communicate
and present information and
ideas properly now talking about their
salary
a data scientist in india can expect an
annual salary of 10 lakhs 47 000 rupees
per year
meanwhile in the us they can earn up to
113
000 dollars per annum that's a lot of
money
from the many companies hiring for data
scientists here we have a few companies
named
they are yet again amazon citibank apple
google the japanese electronic commerce
and online retailing company rakuten and
facebook
and finally we have machine learning
engineer
machine learning engineers are
professionals who develop intelligent
machines that can learn from
vast amounts of data and apply knowledge
without human intervention
they use different algorithms and
statistical modeling to make
sense of data they design and develop
machine learning
and deep learning algorithms their main
goal is to create
self-running software let's have a look
at the responsibilities of a machine
learning engineer
machine learning engineers research
design and develop machine learning
systems
they use exceptional mathematical skills
in order to perform faster computations
and work with algorithms to create
sophisticated models
they perform a b testing and use data
modeling to fine-tune the results
they use data modeling and evaluation
strategy to find hidden patterns and
predict
unseen instances machine learning
engineers work
closely with data engineers to build
data pipelines
and interact with stakeholders to get a
clarity on the requirements
most importantly they analyze complex
data sets to verify data quality
perform model tests and experiments
choose to implement the right machine
learning algorithm
and select the right training data sets
moving on to their skills a machine
learning engineer should have a degree
in computer science and information
technology
they should have an advanced degree in
computer science or maths
in addition to this they should also
have experience in the same domain
they should be proficient in programming
languages such as python
rc plus plus and java knowledge of
statistics probability and linear
algebra is necessary as
all the machine learning algorithms have
been derived from mathematics
also having an idea of signal processing
would be beneficial
machine learning engineers need to have
a good understanding of data
manipulation and machine learning
libraries such as numpy panda
scikit-learn etc
they should have good oral and written
communication skills
let us now have a look at their salary
structure
a machine learning engineer earns 8 lakh
rupees per annum in india
while in the us they can earn around 114
000 dollars a year
now that's a whopping amount isn't it
let's have a look at the companies
hiring machine learning engineers
so as you see we have amazon microsoft
oracle salesforce rapido
and accenture to name a few that was all
about the job role of a machine learning
engineer
now that we have seen the different job
roles in the field of data analytics
let's also go ahead and see how an ideal
resume of a data analyst
should look like seen on your screens is
a sample resume of a data analyst
you can grab some ideas from this and
incorporate them in your resume
nowadays it's quite common to have a
professional photograph of yours on the
resume
you can go ahead and have that then your
name in bold
followed by your contact details like
email id
and phone number then moving on you
would have to write a summary
briefly explain your current job role
and what you're looking for in the
future
having a linkedin profile link works
well these days
employers can just go ahead and look at
your profile and gauge you well
make sure to have an active linkedin
profile
in addition to linkedin profile it's
also good to have a github profile link
which can show your coding or
other technical skills if it's
impressive enough then a lot of times
the rest of your resume is just
secondary
as i mentioned this is a resume of a
data analyst so as you can see in the
summary here we have just spoken about
the basic responsibilities of a data
analyst
moving on to the experience part you
have to write the job title and below
that you can mention the company and the
tenure accordingly
here you would have to give a brief
description of achievements in the
organization
any relevant accomplishments related to
the job you're applying for
the tools and the various technologies
you have worked with
so in this sample you can see we have
spoken about data visualization using r
in tableau
next we have spoken about how the
candidate has worked with other teams
for a better business outcome
most of the data and lists use sql and
excel to handle data for reporting and
database maintenance
and we have mentioned that here as well
do make sure that you always specify the
tools you use
then you can also mention if you have
worked on improving data delivery
for example here we have spoken about
developing and optimizing sql queries
data aggregations and etl to improve
data delivery
finally you can speak a bit about your
reporting skills and if needed elaborate
on it
usually professionals would have worked
in a similar domain before becoming a
data analyst
here we have taken the role of a
statistical assistant as the first job
since it's easier for a candidate with
this job role to shift into the data
analytics field
nevertheless y'all can still mention
your prior experience here
be it in any domain under the
responsibilities for this job role
we have given basics such as coding data
prior to computer entry
compiling statistics from various
reports computing
and analyzing data and finally some
visualization and reporting
moving to the education here you can
mention the name of your degree and the
university name
if you have a post graduation well in
good you can list both the degrees here
also if you have any certifications you
can mention them here under the
education category
now moving to the skills depending on
your skills and your choice you can
either shift this part to the beginning
of the resume or have it here
as you see on your screens this is just
a different way of displaying your skill
sets
you can have all the five stars colored
if you are excellent in that particular
tool or language
as you see it's crystal clear as to what
the candidate's strong areas are
you can have various categories like
shown for example
under software development you can list
the languages that you know and how
proficient you are in those particular
languages
it's clear that the candidate knows
python better than javascript here
so the employer gets a clear idea about
the skills you possess
and the depth of it similarly you can
mention the databases as well
the few mentioned here are more or less
a requirement to become a data analyst
at least sql is a must
not to forget data visualization is also
very important when it comes to the job
role of a data analyst
mention the tools you know here and
similarly give yourself a rating out of
five
five stars shaded being the highest
here we have mentioned tableau and excel
which are more than sufficient to become
a data analyst
moving to the non-technical skills you
can mention the languages you know here
here we have taken english and german in
addition to the languages you can also
feel free to mention the extracurricular
activities that you are good at
so this is how an ideal resume of a data
analyst should look like
you can alter it according to your
achievements skills
and experience hello everyone we have an
exciting topic for today
and that is data scientist versus data
analyst
currently all of us are living in an
information driven world
and organizations rely on data for
various decision making
this in turn provides a lot of job
opportunities for candidates who can
play with data
out of the many job roles in the field
of data science the two popular ones are
that of a data scientist and a data
analyst
haven't we all wondered at some point as
to what the exact difference is between
these two job roles
oh wait are they the same well they
differ in various ways
and you will see how in this video
we will start off by looking at the job
descriptions of both the data scientist
and the data analyst
then we will look at their
responsibilities and skill set
we will also have a look at their salary
structure and the various companies
hiring for these professionals
so without further ado let's get started
let's have a look at the job description
now
a data scientist is a professional who
uses different statistical methods data
analysis techniques
and machine learning in order to
understand and analyze data
in order to arrive at business
conclusions
they proactively fetch information from
a plethora of sources and analyze it for
better understanding
about how the business performs and they
also build ai tools that automate
certain processes within the company
they derive meaning out of messy and
unstructured data
a data scientist is usually a senior
most member in the team
moving to the description of data
analyst a data analyst is responsible to
collect
process and perform analysis on large
data sets
they deal with data handling data
modeling and reporting
they are sometimes the entry level
members into the data analytics team
they bring technical expertise to ensure
the quality and accuracy of the data
then process design and present it in
ways to help people
businesses and organizations make better
decisions
after a few years of experience data
analysts can move into the roles of a
data engineer and a data scientist
now that we have understood the job
descriptions let's go ahead and
understand the various roles and
responsibilities of a data scientist and
a data analyst
firstly data scientists are responsible
for performing cleaning processing and
manipulation of data
using several data analytics tools they
also perform ad hoc data mining and
collect
large sets of structured and
unstructured data from a number of
sources
secondly data scientists interpret the
data using various statistical methods
they design and evaluate advanced
statistical models to work on big data
thirdly data scientists regularly build
predictive models and machine learning
algorithms to work on vast volumes of
data
lastly data scientists use visualization
packages and tools to create reports and
dashboards for relevant stakeholders
they also work with data analysts and
data engineers to formulate the analysis
results
let's now have a look at the various
responsibilities of a data analyst
the first responsibility of a data
analyst is to recognize and understand
the company's goal
this in turn helps in streamlining the
whole analysis process
they are required to assess the
available resources comprehend the
business problem and gather the right
set of data
this step is done by collaborating with
different team members such as data
scientists
business analysts and programmers
they gather data from various databases
and warehouses through querying
they write complex sql queries and
scripts to gather
and extract information
data analysts also filter and clean data
to get the required information
they are responsible for data mining as
well data is mined from various sources
and then organized in order to obtain
new information from it
data and lists identify and analyze
trends in complex data sets
using various statistical tools
a data analyst is also responsible for
creating summary reports for the
leadership team so that they can make
timely decisions
data analysts use multiple data
visualization tools for achieving this
in order to achieve all the above
mentioned responsibilities data
scientists and data analysts are
required to possess a rich skill set
let's now have a look at few of the most
important skills required to back the
position of a data scientist
the basic requirement to become a data
scientist is that you must have a
bachelor's degree in computer science or
information technology
but a master's degree in the field of
data science will be a lot more
beneficial
you also need to have a good experience
in the analytics domain
as i mentioned before this role is a
senior role and to get here the right
amount of experience is a must
let's have a look at the tools you need
to know
knowledge of microsoft excel is good it
is one of the most basic requirements
speaking of programming languages you
should be good at python c plus plus and
java knowledge of perl is a brawny point
you should also be proficient in sql
as we discussed earlier data scientists
work on building machine learning
algorithms
hence you need to have a good knowledge
of machine learning and deep learning
familiarity with apache spark apache
hive and apache pig is necessary along
with the knowledge of hadoop
data visualization and bi skills are
necessary for creating reports and
dashboards
you should also be able to communicate
and present information and ideas
clearly
so these are the skills required to
become a data scientist
if you want to explore the role of a
data analyst then you should hold a
degree in any relevant field beat
engineering in computer science
information technology or electrical
engineering
you can also be a graduate in statistics
or economics
moving on to the tools once again you
should be familiar with microsoft excel
the next important skill is that you
should have good hands-on experience
with programming languages such as
python
r and javascript this would help you
write programs to solve complex problems
you should also have a good knowledge of
statistical and data analytics tools
such as sas
minor and ssas
you must be able to write various sql
queries and procedures
in addition to these you must have a
strong understanding of statistics and
machine learning algorithms
these include concepts such as
hypothesis testing probability
distributions and various classification
and clustering techniques
most importantly a data analyst should
be able to create
visually appealing reports with the help
of charts and graphs using several data
visualization tools
such as power bi and tableau
they must possess good presentation
skills as well in order to convey
their ideas to the clients and
stakeholders in a better way
so these are the skills that are
required to become a data analyst
let's now have a look at the annual
salary range of a data scientist and a
data analyst
both in the us and in india
in the united states a data scientist
can earn a minimum salary of 61 thousand
dollars to a maximum of 136
000 per year
meanwhile in india a data scientist can
earn a minimum salary of 3 lakh 47
000 rupees to a maximum of 2 million
rupees per annum
a date analyst in the united states can
earn a minimum salary of forty three
thousand dollars to a maximum of eighty
five thousand dollars per year
in india you can earn anywhere between
one lakh ninety eight thousand rupees to
nine lakh
twenty four thousand rupees per annum
let's now take a look at the various
companies hiring data scientists and
data analysts
here we have amazon the internet and
search engine giant google
deloitte the american multinational
technology company microsoft
then we have apple and the american
social media web and mobile application
company pinterest
hiring data scientists
from the many companies hiring data
analysts here we once again have
amazon then we have the popular retail
company walmart
robertoff and atnt next we have social
media firms facebook and twitter
as you might have heard of the term data
never sleeps well it surely doesn't and
not only that but it also brings in a
number of job opportunities with it
the job group in this domain is
limitless and data will only continue to
grow
let's have a look at few of the stats
now
well ibm had predicted that by this year
that is 2020 the number of job listings
in the field of data science and
analytics will increase by 3 lakh 64
000.
and we have the u.s bureau of labor
statistics predicting that there will be
a rise in the data science needs and
this in turn will create 11.5 million
job openings by 2026
now that's a big number isn't it
and if you are aspiring to become a data
scientist then you are on the right path
as there is a huge demand for this role
according to deloitte the united states
is projected to face a shortfall of 2
lakh 50 000 data scientists by 2024
that's barely just in four more years
all these stats prove that the job
demand in the field of data science and
data analytics is here to stay
professionals belonging to this domain
are in high demand all across the globe
now let's have a look at the google
search trends for data scientists and
data analysts
as you see the blue color depicts data
scientists and the red data analysts
both the search trends go hand in hand
and over time the search term data
analyst is higher
but the search term of that of a data
scientist is experiencing a steady rise
let's have a look at the worldwide
youtube search trend as well
as you can see on your screens it looks
like people are more keen on exploring
the job role of a data scientist
and looks like they want to learn more
about the job role of a data scientist
compared to that of a data analyst
nevertheless the search term data
analyst is also right there in the
competition
now richard will help us understand the
top data and list interview questions
today we're going to jump into some
common questions you might see
on numpy arrays and pandas data frames
and the python
along with some excel tabloo and sql
let's start with our first question what
is the difference between data
mining and data profiling
it's real important to note that data
mining is a process of finding relevant
information which has not been found
before it is a way in which raw data is
turned into valuable information
you can think of this as anything from
the cells
stats and from their sql server all the
way to web scraping and census bureau
information where the heck do you mine
it from where do you get all this data
and information
then we look at data profiling is
usually done to assess a data set for
its uniqueness consistency and logic
it cannot identify incorrect or
inaccurate data values
so if somebody has a statistical
analysis on one side
and they're doing their you might in the
wrong data to then program your
data set up so you got to be aware that
when you're talking about data mining
you need to look at the integrity of
what you're bringing in where it's
coming from
data profiling is looking at it and
saying hey how is this going to work
what's the logic what's the consistency
is it related to what i'm working with
find the term data wrangling and data
analytics
data wrangling is a process of cleaning
structuring and enriching the raw
data into a desired usable format for
better decision making
and you can see a nice chart here with
our discover it we structure the data
how we want it we clean it up get rid of
all those null values
we enrich it so we might take and
reformat some of the settings instead of
having
five different terms for height of
somebody you know in america in english
or whatever
clean some of that up and we might do a
calculation and bring some of them
together
and validate i was just talking about
that the last one need to validate
your data make sure you have a solid
data source and then of course it goes
into the analysis
very important to notice here in data
wrangling
eighty percent of data analytics is
usually in this whole part of wrangling
the data
getting it to fit correctly and don't
confuse that with data cooking which is
actually when you're going into neural
networks
cooking the data so it's all between
zero and one values
what are common problems that data
analysts
encounter during analysis
handling duplicate and missing values
collecting the meaningful right
data the right time making data secure
and dealing with compliance issues
handling data purging and storage
problems again we're talking about data
wrangling here
eighty percent of most jobs are
unwrangling that data and getting it in
the right format
making sure it's good data to use
number four what are the various steps
involved in
any analytics project
understand the problem we might spend 80
percent
doing wrangling but you better be ready
to understand the problem because if you
can't
you're going to spend all your time in
the wrong direction this is probably
the most important part of the process
everything after it falls in
and then you can come back to it two
data collection
data cleaning number three four data
exploration analysis
and five interpret the results
number five is a close second for being
the most important
if you can't interpret what you bring to
the table to your clients you're in
trouble
so when this question comes up you
probably want to focus on those two
noting that the rest of it does eighty
percent of the work is in two three and
four
well one and five are the most important
parts
which technical tools have you used for
analysis and presentation purposes
being a data analyst you are expected to
have knowledge of the below tools
for analysis and presentation purposes
there's a wide variety out there
sql server mysql
you have your excel your spss which is
the ibm platform
tableau python you have all these
different tools in here
now certainly a lot of jobs are going to
be narrowed in on just a few of these
tools like you're not going to have
a microsoft sql server mysql server
but you better understand how to do
basic sql polls
it's also understanding excel and how
the different formats
for column and how to get those set up
number six what are the best practices
for data cleaning
this is really important to remember to
go through this in detail these always
come up because
80 percent of most data analysis
in cleaning the data make a data
cleaning plan by understanding where the
common errors take place
and keep communications open identify
and remove duplicates before working
with the data
this will lead to an effective data
analysis process
focus on the accuracy of the data
maintain the value types of data
provide mandatory constraints and set
cross-field
validation standardize the data at the
point of entry so that is less chaotic
and you will be able to ensure that all
the information is standardized
leading to fewer errors on entry number
seven
how can you handle missing values in a
data set
list wise deletion in list wise deletion
method entire record is excluded from
analysis if any single value is missing
sometimes we're talking about records
remember this could be a single line in
a database
so if you have your sql comes back and
you have
15 different columns every one of those
has a missing value you might just drop
it
just to make it easy because you already
have enough data to do the processing
average imputation use the average value
of the responses from the other
participants to fill in the missing
value
this is really useful and they'll ask
you why these are useful i guarantee it
if you have a whole group of data that's
collected and it doesn't have that
information in it
at that point you might average it in
there regression substitution
you can use multiple regression analysis
to estimate a missing value
that kind of goes with the average
imputation input
regression model means you're just going
to get you're going to actually generate
a
prediction as to what you think that
value should be for those people based
on the ones you do have
multiple imputation so we talk about
multiple inputs
it creates plausible values based on the
correlations for the missing
data and then average the simulated data
sets by incorporating
random errors in your predictions
what do you understand by the term
normal distribution
and the second you hear the word normal
distribution should be thinking a bell
curve like we see
here normal distribution is a type of
continuous probability distribution that
is
symmetric about the mean and in the
graph normal distribution
will appear as a bell curve the mean
median and mode are equal that's a quick
way to know if you have normal
distribution is you can compute mean
median and mode
all of them are located at the center of
the distribution 68 percent of the data
lies within one
standard deviation of the mean 95
percent of the data falls within two
standard deviations of the mean 99.7
of the data lies within three standard
deviations of the mean
what is time series analysis
time series analysis is a statistical
method that deals with
ordered sequence of values of a variable
of equally spaced
time intervals time series data on a
coveted 19 cases
and you can see we're looking at by days
so our space is of days and each day
goes by
if we take and graph it you can see a
time series graph always looks really
nice we have like two different
in this case we have what the united
states going over there
i'd have to look at the other set up in
there they picked a couple different
countries
uh and it is it's time sensitive you
know with the next result
is based on what the last one was kova
is an excellent example of this
anytime you do any word analytics where
you're figuring out what someone's
saying
what they said before makes a huge
difference is what they're going to say
next another form of time series
analysis
10. how is joining different from
blending
in tableau so now we're going to jump
into the tableau package
data joining data joining can only be
done
when the data comes from the same source
combining two tables from the same
database or two or more worksheets from
the same
excel file all the combined tables or
sheets
contains common set of dimensions and
measures
data blending data blending is used when
the data is from two or more
different sources combining the oracle
table with the sql server
or two sheets from excel or combining
excel sheet and oracle table
in data blending each data source
contains its own set of dimensions
and measures how is overfitting
different from underfitting always a
good one
overfitting probably the biggest danger
in data analytics today is overfitting
model trains from the data too well
using the training set
the performance drops significantly over
the test set
happens when the model learns the noise
and random fluctuations in the training
data set in detail
and again the performance drops way
below
what the test set has the model neither
trains a data well nor
can generalize to new data performs
poorly both on
train and the test set happens when
there is less data to build
and an accurate model and also when we
try to build a linear model with a
non-linear data
in microsoft excel a numeric value can
be treated as a text value
if it proceeds with an apostrophe
definitely not an exclamation if you're
used to programming in python you'll
look for that hash code
and not an amber sign and we can see
here
if you enter the value 10 into a fill
but you put the apostrophe in front of
it
it will read that as a text not as a
number
what is the difference between count
count a
count blank and count if in excel
we can see here when we run in just
count
d1 through d23 we get 19
and you'll notice that there is 19
numbers coming down here
and so it doesn't count the cost of each
which is a top
bracket it doesn't count the blank
spaces either with the straight count
when you do a count a you'll get the
answer is 20. so now when you do count a
counts all of them even the title cost
of each
when you do count blank we'll get three
why there's three blank fields
and finally the count if if we do count
if of e
1 to e 23 is greater than 10 there's 11
values in there basic counting of
whatever's in your column pretty solid
on the table there
explain how vlookup works in excel
vlookup is used when you need to find
things in a table or a range by row
the syntax has four different parts to
it
we have our lookup value that's a value
you want to look up we have our table
array
the range where the lookup value is
located
column index number the column number
and range that contains the return value
and the range lookup specify true if you
want an approximate match or false if
you want an exact match of the return
value
so here we see vlookup f3
a2 to c8 2 0 for prints
now they don't show the f3 f3 is the
actual
cell that prince is in that's what we're
looking at is f3 so there's your prince
he pulls in from f3
a2 to c8 is the the data we're looking
into
and then number two is a column in that
data so in this case we're looking for
uh
age and we count name as one ages two
keep in mind this is excel versus a lot
of your
python and programming languages where
you start at zero
in excel we always look at the cells as
one two
three so two represents the age
zero is false for having an exact match
up
versus one we don't actually need to
worry about that too much in this
zero or one would work with this example
and you can see with the
angela lookup again her name would be in
the f column number four that's what the
f4 stands for is
where they pulled angela from and then
you have a1 to c8
and then we're looking at number three
so number three is height
name being one h2 and then height three
and you'll see here pulls in her height
5.8 so
we're going to run jump over to sql how
do you subset or filter
data in sql to subset or filter data in
sql we use
where and having clause you can see we
have a nice table on the left where we
have the title the director the year
the duration we want to filter the table
for movies that were directed by
brad bird why just because we want to
know who
what brad bird did so we're going to do
select star
you should know that the star refers to
all in this case we're what are we going
to return we're going to return all
title directory year and duration that's
what we mean by all
from movies movies being our table where
director equals brad bird and you can
see
he comes back and he did the incredible
and ratatouille
to subset or filter data sql we can also
use the
where and having clause so we're going
to take a closer look at the
different ways we can filter here filter
the table for directors whose movies
have an
average duration greater than 115
minutes
so there's a lot of really cool things
into this sql
query and these sql queries can get
pretty crazy select
director sum duration as total duration
average duration as average duration
from movies
group by director having average
duration
greater than 115. uh so again what are
we going to return we're going to return
whatever we put in our select which in
this case is director
we're going to have total duration and
that's going to be the sum of the
duration
we're going to have the average duration
average underscore duration which is
going to be the average duration on
there
and then we course go ahead and group by
director
and we want to make sure we group them
by anyone that has an
having an average duration greater than
115.
these sql queries are so important i
don't know how many times your
the sql comes up and there's so many
different other languages not just mysql
and not microsoft sql in addition to
that
where the sql language comes in
especially with hadoop and other areas
so you really should know your basic sql
doesn't hurt to get that little cheat
sheet and glance over and double check
some of the different features in sql
what is the difference between where and
having clause in sql
where where clause works on row data
in where clause the filter occurs before
any groupings
are made aggregate functions cannot be
used
so the syntax is select your columns
from table where what the condition is
having clause works on aggregated data
having is used to filter values from a
group
aggregate functions can be used in the
syntax is select column names from table
where the condition is grouped by
having a condition ordered by column
names
what is the correct syntax for reshape
function in
numpy so we're going to jump to the
numpy array program
and what you come up with is you have uh
in this case would be numpy.reshape a
lot of times you do an import numpy as
np
reshape and then your array and the new
shape
and you can see here as we as the actual
example comes in the reshape is a and
we're going to reshape it in two comma
five setups and you see the printout in
there that prints in
two rows with five values in each one
what are the different ways to create a
data frame in pandas
well we can do it by initializing a list
so you can port your
pandas as pd very common data equals tom
30 jerry20 angela35 we'll go ahead and
create the data frame
and we'll say pd.dataframe is the data
columns equals name and age so you can
designate your columns you can also
it is a index in there you should always
remember that the index
uh in this case maybe you want the index
instead of 1 2 to be
the date they signed up or who knows you
know whatever and you can see right
there it just generates a nice
pandas data frame with tom jerry and
angela
another way you can initialize a data
frame is from dictionary
you can see here we have a dictionary
where the date equals name
tom jerry angela mary ages 20 21 1918
and if we do a dfpd dot data frame on
the data
you'll get a nice the same kind of setup
you get your name age tom jerry angela
and mary
write the python code to create an
employee's data frame from the
emp.csv file and display the head and
summary of it
to create a data frame in python you
need to import the pandas library and
use the read
csv function to load the csv file
and here you can see we have import
pandas as pd employees
or the data frame employees equals
pd.read csv
and then you have your path to that csv
file
there's a number of settings in the read
csv where you can
tell it how many rows are the top index
you can set the columns in there you can
have
skip rows there's all kinds of things
you can also go in there and double
check with your read csv but the most
basic one is just to read a basic csv
how will you select the department and
age columns from an employee's
data frame so we have import pandas as
pd
you can see we have created our data we
will go ahead and create our employees
pd data frame on the left
and then on the right to select
department and age from the data frame
we just do employees and you put the
brackets around it
now if you're just doing one column you
could do just department
but if you're doing multiple columns
you've got to have those in a second set
of
brackets it's got to be a reference with
a list within the reference
what is the criteria to say whether a
developed data model
is good or not a good model should be
intuitive
insightful and self-explanatory
follow the old saying kiss keep it
simple
the model develops should be able to
easily consumed
by the clients for actionable and
profitable results
so if they can't read it what good is it
a good model should easily adapt to
changes
according to business requirements we
live in quite a dynamic world nowadays
so it's pretty self-evident
and if the data gets updated the model
should be able to scale accordingly to
the new data
so you have a nice data pipeline going
where when something when you get new
data coming in you don't have to go and
rewrite the whole code
what is the significance of exploratory
data analysis
exploratory data analysis is an
important step in any data analysis
process
exploratory data analysis eda helps to
understand the data better
it helps you obtain confidence in your
data to a point where you're ready to
engage a machine learning algorithm
it allows you to refine your selection
of feature variables
that will be used later for model
building you can discover hidden trends
and insights
from the data how do you treat outliers
in a data set an outlier is a data point
that is distant from
other similar points they may be due to
variability in the measurement or may
indicate experimental errors
one you can drop the outlier records
pretty straightforward
you can cap your outliers data so it
doesn't go
past a certain value you can assign it a
new value
you can also try a new transformation to
see if those outliers come in if you
transform it slightly differently
explain descriptive predictive and
prescriptive analytics descriptive
provides insights into the past to
answer what has happened
uses data aggregation and data mining
techniques
examples an ice cream company can
analyze how much ice cream
was sold which flavors were sold and
whether more or less ice cream was sold
than before predictive
understands the future to the answer
what could happen
uses statistical models and forecasting
techniques
example predicts the sale of ice creams
during the summer spring and rainy days
so this is always interesting because
you have your descriptive which comes in
and your businesses are always looking
to know what happened hey did we have
good sales last
quarter what are we expecting next
quarter in the cells
and we have a huge jump when we do uh
prescriptive
suggest various courses of action to
answer
what should you do uses optimization and
simulation algorithms to advise possible
outcomes
example lower prices to increase sell of
ice creams produce more or less
quantities of certain flavor of ice
cream and we can certainly uh
today's world with the coveted virus
because we had that in our earlier graph
you could see that as a descriptive
what's happened how many people have
been infected how many people have died
in an area
predictive where do we predict that to
go
um do we see it going to get worse is it
going to get better what do we predict
that we're going to need in hospital
beds
and prescriptive what can we
change in our setup to have a better
outcome
maybe if we did more social distancing
if we tracked the virus
how do these different things directly
affect the end
and can we create a better ending by
changing some underlying
criteria what are the different types of
sampling techniques used by data
analysis
sampling is a statistical method to
select a subset of data from an entire
data set
population to estimate the
characteristics of the whole population
one we can do a simple random sampling
so we can just pick out 500 random
people in the united states to sample
them
they call it a population in regular
data we also call that a population
just because that's where it came from
was mainly from doing census
systematic sampling cluster sampling
stratified sampling and judgment or
propositive sampling then we have our
systematic sampling that's where you're
doing like
using 1 5 10 15
20 use a very systematic approach for
pulling samples
uh from the setup cluster sampling
that's where we look at it we say hey
some of these things just naturally
group together
if you were talking about population
which is the really a nice way of
looking at this
cluster sampling would be maybe by a zip
code we're going to do
everybody's zip code and just naturally
cluster it that way
stratified sampling would be more uh
looking for
shared things a group has like income
so if you're studying something on
poverty you might look at their
naturally group people based on income
to begin with and then
study those individuals in the income to
find out what kind of traits they have
and then judgmental that is
where the researcher very carefully
selects each member of their own group
so it's very much based on their
personal knowledge
jumping on the 26 what are the different
types of hypothesis
testing hypothesis testing is a
procedure used by stations and
scientists to
accept or reject statistical hypothesis
we start with a hypothesis testing we
have null hypothesis
and alternative hypothesis on the null
hypothesis
it states that there is no relation
between the predictor and the outcome
variables in the population
it is denoted by h naught example
there is no association between patients
bmi
and diabetes alternative hypothesis
it states there is some relation between
the predictor and outcome variables in
the population it is denoted by
h1 example there could be an association
between patients bmi and diabetes
and that's the body mass index if you
didn't catch the bmi and you're not
medical
describe univariate bivariate and
multivariate
analysis a univariate analysis it is the
simplest form of data analysis where the
data being analyzed
contains only one variable an example of
studying the heights of players
in the nba because it's so simple it can
be
described using central tendencies
dispersion
quartiles bar charts histograms pie
charts
frequency distribution tables the
bivariate analysis
it involves analysis of two variables to
find causes
relationships and correlations between
the variables
example analyzing sale of ice creams
based on the temperature outside
bivariate analysis can be explained
using correlation coefficients
linear regression logistic regression
scatter plots and box plots
and multivariate analysis it involves
analysis
of three or more variables to understand
the relationship of each variable
with the other variables example
analyzing revenue based on expenditure
so if we have our tv ads we have our
newspaper ads our social media ads
and a revenue we can now compare all
those together
the multivert analysis can be performed
using multiple regression
factor analysis classification and
regression trees
cluster analysis principle component
analysis
clustering bar chart dual axis chart
what function would you use to get the
current date and time
in excel in excel you can use the today
and now function to get the current date
and time
and you can see down here with the two
examples where just equals today or
equals now
using the sumifs function in excel
find the total quantity sold by sales
representatives
whose names start with a and the cost of
each item they have sold
is greater than 10. and you can see here
on the left we have our actual table
and then we want to go ahead and sum ifs
so we want the e2 through e20
b2 through b20 greater than 10.
and this basically is just saying hey
we're going to take everything
in the e column and we're going to sum
it up but only those
objects where the d column is greater
than 10
that's what that means there is the
below query correct
if not how will you rectify it
select customer id year order date
as order year from order where
order year is greater than or equal to
2016.
and hopefully you caught it right there
uh it's in the
devils in the details we can't not use
the alias name while filtering data
using the where clause
so the correct format is all the same
except for where it says where
the year order date is greater than or
equal to 16
versus using the order year which we
assign under the select setup
how are union intersect and accept
used in sql the union operator is used
to combine the results of two or more
select statements
and you can see here we have select star
from region 1
and we're going to make a union with
select star from region 2
and it basically takes both these sql
tables and combines them to form a full
new table on there
so that's your union as we bring
everything together we look at the
intersect operator returns the common
records that are the result of the two
or more select statements
so you can see here we select star from
region one intersect select star from
region 2
and we come up with only those records
that are shared that have the same data
in them
and hopefully you jumped ahead to the
accept
the accept operator returns the uncommon
records that are the result of two or
more select
statements so these are the red two
records or the records that are not
shared between the two databases
using the product price table write
an sql query to find the record with the
fourth
highest market price
so here we have a little bit of a brain
teaser
they're always fun and the first thing
we want to do is we're going to go ahead
and
i'm going to if you look at the script
on the left
we really want the fourth one down so
we're gonna select the top
four from product price but we're gonna
order it
by market price descending sp order by
market price
ascending so we do is we take the top
four of the market price ascending
and that's going to give us the four
greatest values
and then we're going to reverse that
order and do descending and we're going
to take the top one of that which is
going to give us the lowest value
which would be the fourth greatest one
in the list
from the product price table find the
total and average
market price for each currency where the
average market price is greater than 100
and currency is in the inr or the aud
so inr or aud india rupal
or australia dollar you can see over
here the sql
query if you had trouble putting this
together
you might actually do some of it in
reverse
and you can see right here where the
average market price is greater than 50
remember we use having not where at the
end because it's part of the group
so group by currency because we want
those two currencies
and we want the currency india the inr
or the aud
and as you keep going backwards we're
actually going to be selecting the
currency the sum of the market price as
total price
and the average marketplace as average
price
so there's our select it's going to come
from the product price which is just our
table over there
and then we have where our currency is
in and like i said you can put together
however you want but hopefully you got
to the end there
so this question will test your
knowledge in tableau
exploring the different features of
tableau and creating a suitable graph to
solve a business
problem and of course taboo is very
visual in its use
so it's very hard to test it without
actually just getting your hands on
and if you can't visualize some of this
and how to do it then you should go back
and refresh yourself
using the sample superstore data set
create a view
to analyze the cells profits and
quantities sold across
different subcategories of items present
under each
category so the first step is to go
ahead and load
the sample superstore data set so make
sure you know how to load the sample
the superstore data set that's
underneath either the connect button in
the upper left
or the tableau icon up there and be able
to pull in the data set
and then once you've done that you just
drag the category and subcategory on
rows and salaries onto
columns it will result in a horizontal
bar chart so in this one we're just
going to drag a profit
onto color and quantity onto label
sort the sales axes in descending order
of sum and cells within each
sub category
and if you're at home doing this you'll
see that chairs under furniture category
had the highest sales and profit while
tables had the lowest profit
for office supplies subcategory binders
made the highest profit
even though storage had the highest
sales under technology category copiers
made the highest profit
though it was the least amount of sales
let's work to create a dual axis chart
in tableau to present
cells and profits across different years
using sample superstore data set load
the
orders sheet from the sample superstore
data set
drag the ordered data field from the
dimensions
onto columns and convert it into
continuous month
cells onto rows and profits to the right
corner of the view
until you see a light green rectangle
one of those things if you haven't done
this hands-on
you don't know what you're doing you're
gonna run into a bike so you're gonna be
just kind of dropping it and wondering
what happened synchronize the right axis
by right clicking
on the profit axis and then let's
finalize it by going under the
marks card change some cells to bar and
sum
profit to line and adjust the size
and then we have a nice display that we
can either print out or save and send
off to the
shareholders let's go and do one more
tableau design a view in tableau to show
state statewide cells and profits using
the sample superstore data set
in here you go ahead and drag the
country field onto the view section and
expand it to see the states
drag the states field onto size and
profit
onto color increase the size of the
bubbles
at a border and a halo color states like
washington california and new york have
the highest sales and profits while
texas pennsylvania and ohio
have a good amount of sales but the
least amount of profits
we'll go ahead and skip back to python
numpy
suppose there is an array number equals
np or numpy if you're using numpy
depending on how you set
it up dot array and we just have one to
nine
broken up into three groups extract the
value
eight using 2d indexing
so you can see on the left we have our
import numpy as in p number equals our
np array
if we print the number we have one two
three four five six seven eight nine
since the value eight is present in the
second row and first
column we use the same index position
and pass it
to the array you just have number two
comma one and you get eight
and remember we're in python so you
start at zero
not one like you do in excel always gets
me if i'm
working between excel and python where i
just kind of flip and usually it's the
excel that messes up because i do a lot
more programming
suppose there's an array that has values
0 1
all the way up to 9. how will you
display the following values from the
array
1 3 5 7 9.
so first of all we go ahead and create
the array np dot
a range of 10 which goes from 0 to 9
because there's 10 numbers in it but we
don't include the 10.
we print it out the first thing you want
to do is what's going on here with one
three five
seven nine well if we divide by
two there's going to be a remainder
equal to one
and then from python remember that if
you use the percentage sign
you get the remainder on there so the
remainder is one
and then you have the your numpy array
and then we
just want to do a logical statement of
all values that have a remainder of one
and that generates our nice
one three five seven nine
there are two arrays a and b stack the
arrays a and b
horizontally boy these horizontal
vertical questions will get you every
time
and in numpy we go ahead and we've
created two different arrays over here a
and b
the first one is your concatenate np dot
concatenate
a and b on axes equal one
that is the same as h stack
and in the back end they're still
identical they run the same that's all
hdac is a concatenate
axis equals one how can you add
a column to a pandas data frame
suppose there's an imp data frame that
has information about few employees
let's add address column to that data
frame
you can see in the left we have our
basic data frame you should know your
data frames very well
basically it looks like an excel
spreadsheet as you come over here it's
really simple you just
do df of address equals the address once
you've assigned
values to the address
using the below given data create a
pivot table
to find the total sales made by each
cells represented for each item
display the cells as a percentage of the
grand
total so we're back in tableau
select the entire table range click on
insert tab
and choose pivot table
select the table range and the worksheet
where you want to place the pivot table
it will return a pivot table where you
can analyze your data
drag the cell total on the values and
sales rep and item onto row labels
it will give the sum of the sales made
by each representative for each item
they have sold
and finally right click on sum of cell
total and expand
show values as to select percentage of
grand
total real important just to understand
what a pivot
table is we're just piving it from rows
and columns and switching this
direction on there and finally
we have our final pivot table and you
can see the values roles and
sum of total sale so we're going to go
ahead and take a product
table this is off of an sql so we can do
some sql here
and we're going to use the product and
sales order
detail table find the products that have
total units
sold greater than 1.5 million and here's
our sales
order detail table so we have a product
table and a sales order detail table two
separate tables in the database
and we're going to do is put together
the sql query we want to select
pp name sum sod unit price as
cells and then we have our p p dot
product
id from production product as p p
inner join cells dot sales order detail
as sod on pp product id
equals sod.product id group by
pp.name comma pp.product id having a sum
of sod.unitprice greater than the 150
million there that's a mouthful and
again these sql queries they start
looking really crazy until you just
break
them apart and do them step by step
and what we're looking for is the inner
join
and how did you do the group by this
really wanted to know how do you do this
inner join
this comes up so much in sql how do you
pull in the id from one chart and the
information from another chart and the
sum totals on that chart how do you
write a stored
procedure in sql let's create a storage
procedure to find the sum
the squares are the first n natural
numbers
so here we have our formula n times n
plus one times two n plus one
over six and you can see from the
command prompt uh or the setup you have
depending on what your login is the
command is create procedure
square sum one declare our variable at
in of integer as begin and then we're
going to declare the sum of integer
set sum equals n times n plus 1 plus 2
times n plus 1
over 6. and then of course we can go
ahead and print those out print
first cast amber sign in or our variable
as a variable character 20 natural
numbers
print the sum of the square is cast the
at sum as a variable character 40 end
then we do the output display the sum of
the square for first four
natural numbers we have execute square
sum one and then we're going to put in
four
and you can see here where it brings up
the first four natural number sum of
square is
30. write a store procedure to find the
total even
number between two user given numbers
a couple of things to note here first we
go ahead and create our procedure
you have your two different variables
the n1 in two
and we go ahead and begin we're going to
declare our variable count as an integer
we're going to set count equal to
0 and then we have while n is less than
n2 we're going to begin and if n1
remainder 2 equals 0 so we're going to
divide it by 2
even number begin we're going to set the
count equal to count plus
one we're going to print even number
plus
cast in as a variable character 10 for
printing
count is plus cast variable count as
variable character 10
end else print odd number plus cast
variable number one is variable
character 10. and then we go ahead and
set
the increment our variable one up
one so that goes from n one all the way
to n two
and i'll print the total number of even
numbers and you can see here we went
ahead and executed it
we're going to count the even numbers
between 30 and 45
and you see it goes all the way down to
eight
what is the difference between tree maps
and heat maps in tableau
now if you've worked in python other
programmings you should automatically
know what a heat map
is but a tree map are used to display
data in nested
rectangles you use dimensions to define
the structure of the tree map
and measure to define the size or color
of individual rectangles
tree maps are relatively simple data
visualization that can provide
insight in a visually attractive format
and again you can see the squares over
here this is our tree map over here with
the
each block also has this information
inside of its different blocks
a heat map helps to visualize measures
against dimensions with the help of
colors
and size to compare one or more
dimensions and up to two measures
the layout is similar to a text table
with variations in values encoded as
colors
in heatmap you can quickly see a wide
array of information
and in this one uh you can see they use
the colors to denote one thing
and the size of the little square to
denote something else
a lot of times you can even graph this
into a three-dimensional graph with
other data
so it pops out but again a heat map is
the color and the size
using the sample super stored data set
display the top
five and bottom five customers based on
their profit
so you start by dragging the customer
name field onto rows and profit on
columns right click on the customer name
column to create a set give a name to
the set
and select top tab to choose top 5
customers by some
profit similarly create a set for the
bottom five customers by some profit
select both the sets right click to
create a combined set
give a name to the set and choose all
members in both sets
and then you can drag top and bottom
customer sets onto the filters and
profit filled
onto color to get the desired results
as we get down to the end of our list
we're going to try to keep you
on your toes we're going to skip back to
numpy how
to print four random integers between 1
and
15 using numpy to generate random
numbers using numpy we use the random
random integer function you see here we
did the import numpy is in p
random arrangement equals
np.random.randominteger
1 through 15 of 4.
from the below dataframe can jump again
on you now we're into pandas
how will you find the unique values for
each column and subset the data for
age less than 35 and height greater than
six to find the unique values and the
number of unique elements
use the unique and the in unique
function
you see here we just did df heights
we're selecting just the height column
and we want to look for the unique
that returns an array where in unique
if we do that on the height or the age
will return just the number of unique
values
and then we can do a subset the data for
ages less than 35 and height
greater than six so if we look over here
we have a new df
remember this is going to be taking
slices of our original data frame it
doesn't actually change the data frame
so our new df equals the data frame or
df
the data frame where age is less than 35
and the height is greater than 6.
and in case you're not using tableau
which has a lot of its own
different mapping programs in there make
sure you understand how to use the
basics of
matplot library plot a sine graph using
numpy and matplot library in python
and the way we did this is we went ahead
and generate an x we know our y equals
np.sine of x
if you print out x you'll see a whole
value here our matplot library pi
plot as plt if you are working in
jupiter
notebook make sure you understand the
matplot library inline that little
percentage sign matplot library inline
that prints it on the page in the
jupiter notebook the newer version of
jupyter notebook or
jupiter labs automatically does that for
you but i usually put it in there just
in case i end up on an older version
if you print y you can see here we have
our different y values and our different
x values
you simply put in plt.plot x y
and do a plot show and before we go
let's get
one more in we're going to do a pandas
using the below pandas
data frame find the company with the
highest average
cells derive the summary statistics for
the cells column
and transpose these statistics
that's a mouthful and just like any of
these computer problems break it apart
so first of all we're looking for the
highest average sales so group the
company
column and use the mean function to find
the average sales
you see here by company equals
df.groupby
company once we've done that using the
describe function we can now go ahead
and look at the summary of statistics on
here
use the describe function to find the
summary so
by company those are groups we're just
going to describe them and you could
actually bundle those together if you
wanted and just do them all in one
line so here we go by company dot
describe
you can see we have a nice breakout
always good to remember
whether you're using any of the packages
whether it's tableau
or pandas in python
or even r or some other package being
able to quick look and describe your
data is very important
and then we go ahead and just do a basic
apply a transpose function over the
describe method
to transpose the statistics all we've
done
here is flip the index with the column
names
but if you're following the numbers a
lot of times it's easier to follow
across one line or maybe you want to
average out the count or it's all kinds
of different reasons to do that
with that we have come to the end of
this video tutorial on data analytics
full course
i hope it was interesting and
informative if you have any questions
then please put it in the comments
section of the video don't forget to
subscribe to our youtube channel
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here
you